this is jocko podcast number 276
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
archival publications of the institute
of national
remembrance poland
court name court of the pomeranian
military district b
judge lieutenant colonel joseph
sobitsky court file number
redacted prosecutor's office
file number redacted security service
file number
redacted case examination date
1981 12 14
case conclusion date 1982
12 28 case
description file in the criminal case
against redacted name suspected of
printing
and distributing leaflets containing
false
information that is crime
based on article 48 section 3
of the decree of december 12 1981
on martial law
detained temporarily on february 11 1982
based on the decision of the military
prosecutor's office
february 12 1982
the accused acting together and in
consultation with redacted name
produced brochures for distribution
which could cause
civil disturbances and which contained
false information on activity of
authorities
of the people's republic of poland in
the period of martial law
and calling upon civilians to oppose the
authorities and to organize an illegal
underground
organization that is crime based on
article 48
section 3 of the decree of december 12
1981 on martial law
based on the ruling of the court of the
pomeranian military district
redacted name is sentenced to three
years of imprisonment
and three years of loss of civil rights
a charge to be paid
on behalf of the state treasury in the
amount of
4200 pln
reimbursement of one-third of the costs
of court proceedings
so that is a document
from a book the book is called
camp posey and it's written by
an individual called naval who is a
member of the
polish grom special forces
and the document is from the case
against a
man whose name is redacted
in the document his name is thomas zeron
thomas was born and raised in
communist poland and he made a stand
against the authoritarian communist
regime
and was sent to prison for his actions
sent to prison for speaking out against
the evils
of communism and he ended up in prison
communist prison and i i guess i need
not talk about the condition
of communist prisons because we've
discussed them on this podcast before
but it goes saying
goes without saying that
those prisons are not for the faint of
heart
but luckily thomas zeron possessed an
incredibly strong will
and he survived prison and he made it
out of prison
and eventually he made it out of poland
and eventually he made it to the united
states
where he eventually
joined the navy
and became a seal
this is also where thomas zeron took on
a new name a nickname
drago and this is where
i was lucky enough to serve alongside
him
on and off the battlefield
and this is where we became brothers and
it is an honor
to have him here tonight to share his
story with us drago
welcome thank you it's awesome to be
here on your podcast
uh i follow it for a long time and
eventually i
thank you for inviting me and um it's
honored to be here
yeah somebody on some something reached
out
and said well why don't you have drago
on i was like anytime drago wants to
come on
no no factor of course so
this is like one of the craziest stories
as far as backstories go
not just for joining the seal teams but
joining the military in general i mean
it's pretty straightforward what happens
to most american kids right oh i want to
be a soldier
they join the army the navy the the air
force the marine corps
that's what they do man your story is
about as crazy as it gets for
backstories
i guess it is but for me maybe not crazy
but it's different
and uh just even from uh
well let me just back out a little bit
uh
when i came to america i came with a bag
of clothes and 10
phoenix the germans like less than 10
cents in my pocket
so everything i have
everything i own i
owe it to america to you to american
people
so i promised myself that
i would be the best citizen that america
can have
i'll do everything to be the as good
citizen as
i can be so uh
yes this beginnings were very hard but
but like
no there's not nothing unusual you can't
don't speak english you
you i didn't come here with expectations
like hey give me a job and
make tons of money and i have i just
wanted to work i just wanted to leave
free man and that was given to me so
that promise i i tried to i still keep
it deep in my heart
that yes i am i'm successful i've
succeeded but there is so much more to
do
for america for our country and that's
what i
that was my goal be the best american
citizen america can have so
let's let's take it back a little bit
before you get over here with
less than 10 cents in your pocket so
you're born in poland is that right
you're born in poland yes i was born
you're born in poland
what did your parents do my father was
communist he was
uh he was a professor he was a teacher
then became
became a party member they joined the
polish
that's really not communism more
socialism
they're very the same we can talk about
the differences later but
so my father was a party member my
mother was
was a teacher she was an elementary
school teacher
so when i was born my father was already
starting his career with political
communist polish communist party
now is that is that something that you
you know if you're if you're living in
poland
and you see the communist party on the
rise
your dad looks around and says hey you
know what i kind of gotta
i kind of gotta go with the flow and get
with this party if i'm going to advance
my career in life
i think that's what it was uh but you
know he came from very
poor family too so the opportunity they
gave it to him say look if you just
close your eyes on some moral aspect of
socialism and
just follow that our doctrine and you're
gonna be successful
and he fell for it he went he became
very successful eventually he ended up
in warsaw
in the pretty much the top communist
government
as a one of the directors of
uh ministry of art and culture
so he was successful yeah but it sounds
like
your mom wasn't quite as on board with
looking away from some of those
immoral aspects of communism uh neither
my mom neither
my father's mom i remember that that was
big rift in
our entire family i remember as a little
kid maybe six seven years old visiting
my grandmother
and i mean my father's mother my
grandmother
and she always was telling me communists
are evil they are devils
socialists as evil socialism as evil
system
and i always had the image of socialist
or communist
as the guy with the big tail with the
big horns breathing fire i remember i
even asked
my grandmother that they breathed fire
and uh
my grandma yeah they are wars and they
they murder people quietly on this on
the sides and uh
that they are just really bad as evil
that
so that in my mind was always communism
and socialism as for the evil system it
is
um and i remember my father tried to
protest mom look i'm not evil i'm not
really
uh i'm i'm your son look at him you are
if you sold your soul to
socialism or communism if you that
you're part of these murders that are
quietly happening in poland
so you are evil and i don't even want to
consider you to be my son
that she was very adamant about it so
for me i was like
always remember before going to bed we
were
my my grandmother teach me how to pray
so i was praying that whenever we always
close the prayer of god
please help us take all the communism
communist and socialists out of poland
so i just just kind of grew up with it
and
there's never different and the the rift
with my mom
and and my father i still remember that
was i think it was i don't remember what
age it was but
we wanted to go to church my mother
wanted to go to church uh on sunday
and i still remember my father standing
in front of the door
say we cannot go because i'm going to
lose my job
we cannot go i'm going to lose my job we
are not going to charge
the charge that the communism and charge
and socialism and charge are not
compatible
and we're just not going there so my
grandmother was visiting at the same
time so
my mother left they couldn't he couldn't
stop her my grandmother passed me
through the window
to my mom it was on the first floor
and we still went to the church but uh
that was pretty much
constant raped eventually that that
marriage fell apart
my father went with the communists and
socialists uh
i i stayed with mom my brother my
younger sister stay
with mom so that's was it was
very difficult too for us because at
that time in poland it
changed now but at that time in poland
if your parents divorced you as a child
were stigmatized so you were the
divorcee
you know the exactly that parents would
say hey you don't go play with this guy
because
his parents just got divorced he's just
divorcee like
there was a kind of derogatory name in
polish that we work out so they actually
can't toughen me out because i end up
actually beating up some of these guys
and
they they left me along they were not my
friends but that they never bothered me
again so that worked so what what
uh you're going to school every day is
this like normal
is that what's happening in poland in
the in the this is in the late 70s huh
or the 70s
that was 1968. i remember i'm 60 years
old
so i was born 15 years after second
world war
so this is i was born with a less this
time distance
that we have between we our beginning
between september 11 and uh and and
today
and this is still so fresh in our minds
right september 11th zach happened
yesterday
so i was born just 15 years after the
second world war so i was still playing
the ruins in the broken houses there
were some
people were still finding bombs
unexploded bombs and
explosives uh kind of interesting
so so are you going to school is that is
that normal are they state-run schools
is there communism are you being taught
communism in schools oh yes absolutely i
have actually a couple notes i found
from my
uh from my notebook from school those
elementary school like later classes
like seventh grade about communism and
socialism
yes you were indoctrinated from the very
beginning in socialism and communism
and the things are very uh funny there
because
the government the socialist government
they feel like they need to have a total
control and the russia
they have to but otherwise people just
people don't subscribe to slavery
so so socialism is not really that good
systems and
they don't want it so they they uh i
remember
they forced us in fifth grade
i was in fifth grade elementary school
and we had to learn
russian i was not really i was never the
best student and then they throw the
russian on me as like
for the [ __ ] we like to learn this [ __ ]
i don't want to learn it and i'll kind
of
open up in my in the class i say look
i'm polish i don't want to go into a
land russian language i i don't want to
learn it i don't feel like i'd rather
learn english or rather learn german
oh my god i had no idea what's going to
happen but next thing i was pull out the
principal's office
uh my mother she was a teacher in
different schools so they
they they called the police the secret
set police came in
they picked my mom they drove her to uh
to principal when i was already waiting
there
scared [ __ ] was and they
they say so what happened so that
teacher explained that i am
anti-socialist apparently i don't like
socialism and i
am also objecting to
russian language indoctrinate the
russian indoctrination
so my mom is all in tears she's scared
all shaking then they
dragged my brother into it my sister had
no idea what's going on so we sit up
there or there
and they were very clear i still
remember that if it happens again
these kids will go to orphanage that
government will make them good citizens
if you cannot do that so this is your
last warning
and so i had to rise up a little bit i
never changed my attitude
i was always outspoken but i remember
that fear
that my mom lived for that in the rest
of our lives until
and the rest of the the time when we
were still growing up and the state
could take
the kids away from her so that
that's uh the other interesting part of
it is
that like uh today i have
11 years old 12 years old daughter
11 years old son i'm looking over them
like hulk
i don't let them go anywhere where i can
see them i
i can play but i have to be always able
to go and assist if something happens
what did it happen in poland poland i
remember i was seven
eight i was eight years old i was
driving across the town taking bus
crossing the streets going to somewhere
else and uh it was like there's no big
deal all the kids they were
just 10 miles away from school
where we have to commute and we just
commute it was like no big deal my mom
just bought me a ticket so every time i
got into the bus
if i could because they were so crowded
you just have to pull yourself in and
sometimes the doors are closed so you're
just holding yourself
in it your legs are sticking out but
you're just going to school
so that was kind of yeah there was
like we i don't know it is because we
felt we did feel safe
my mom apparently feels safe about it
and maybe this is because there was no
internet at the time so some of the
crime that happened was not very
transparent
it was not very readily the information
about it was not
readily available so people didn't know
something bad happened so
i remember going to kindergarten so i
was
that was i think i was five and a half
years old so we had to go from uh
from our home i took my younger brother
so he was around me
three and a half and by hand we are
carrying the house shoes in another hand
we had like
the house shoes what's what's house
shoes
slippers because in kindergarten you
cannot wear those shoes that you wear
outside you have to have a slipper so
it has to be clean everything so we had
the slippers in our hands
we're going to around the school around
the street across the street actually a
friend of mine got killed on that street
by the motorcycle so but it was like no
not a big deal so
you when you go across the street you
look left you look right
and make sure nothing is there and we
just walk across the city so we just
walk to a kindergarten by ourselves
being six and a half
plus six five years old so
today i think i would go into jail for
letting things like that happen to my
kids
but at the time was just that was very
common in poland that's
nothing wrong so you're you're you get
this experience
in fifth grade where you basically say
you don't want to learn russian
they they crack down on your mom your
brother your sister
yes did you at any point
were you so were you so you saw what
happened between your mom and your dad
you'd been told your whole life
that communism was evil did so did you
just kind of suppress
that a little bit to to keep from
getting taken away from your mom
i did but maybe not intentionally really
at that time i was not political i was
just like
i would just annoy that i have to have
the language that my grandmother tells
me those people are
not really good and they don't do good
things in poland they
uh they are prayers poland so i don't
have to learn that language
so there was nearly not so much
political but the state was very
political the state was
very uh they were very cautious with
citizens
they wanted to control they did control
almost every aspect of social life
that's what socialism is
uh so that didn't really that
the the political part came later when i
started learning about the mortars the
political murders the oppression
of socialism uh and
then what was became a little bit more
aware of what's going on
then reading about the people
disappearing from the street
and like never heard from them again uh
dad become a little bit more then i
became more aware
and so then
in late 70s in poland it had
so much so enough of these lies because
what happened is we had the empty
shelves there was nothing to eat
and you can buy food you can buy clothes
you cannot buy furniture
but all you hear how great is in poland
in socialist system
if you look at america people are
sleeping on the street and they
you know we had no access to an
information they show those tents or
they show those shacks where poor people
sometimes
stay or they show the worst thing about
america
so that that was just people
knew that this lie so they got so fed up
that eventually no matter what that
socialist press
said people didn't believe if they say
that this is
this is brown people think they know
that
they're lying even if it was brown this
how how
they had enough it had to explode and
that
that thing was accumulating first the
people lost the
faith in in the government they lost
their
faith in the the the truth that's
written the truth
the lies that are being told they
stopped paying attention to it
so at the end no matter what they say
people didn't believe they had enough of
it and it exploded in the
solidarity trade union movement where
that people just raised up
and say enough is enough we had enough
of socialism and communism
when you're when you're um growing up
you talked about fifth grade
you're in eighth grade you're in ninth
grade
you're in tenth grade and i know we're
gonna end up talking about this
at some point you learn how to fight
like not just
what you you learn how to street fight
and you learn how to
fight on some level did you what did you
train you trained taekwondo did you
train boxing what did you train
i started with boxing just regular
boxing and i remember you know
being just my mom growing up uh
my younger brother and sister so
sometimes i had to fight for my brother
too that's quite often
and so the box boxing was
important for me to kind of like uh
codify what are you
already new to just learn maybe this
technical skills now
and it worked great i mean i really
liked it but then
uh again so my brother got beat up at
school
i think because we're divorcees so
there's people just
so i was remember i was sick and uh
i said well i need to go to school then
i just pack my stuff i went to school i
found the big guy that guy was like
huge so i just knock him out and and
and knock him out so bad that this guy
show up with his mom later in the
evening in my apartment and it's like
his mother like see this your son
did that to my son he can lose his eye i
mean
i look at the guy from like behind the
corner and i was like
holy [ __ ] the guy has no eye he's like
big swollen hair
and so my mom just kind of coming in and
she's like look at me i'm like half of
his size
and this guy is huge and he's crying so
uh it's like so that guy bit your son
i was like yeah yeah you see what he did
to him so if your son that big let him
happen to that
i think he deserves that why don't you
just guys leave so
um yeah they left was there a boxing gym
was there a boxing yeah there was one
there
actually there was a program or
something there was official program yes
there actually there was the police club
i didn't know about that time but
the clubs like this were on usually by
the police
so so yeah i belonged they called it
guardia so
so yeah i belong to this club but when i
nailed this guy i broke my hand
i didn't know it so that put me and so
some of my friends went on their
first boxing matches and stuff i just
stay i had to stay home and
okay then we just moved to different
towns so but that was my style was with
the boxing and i liked that
i got involved in the eventually
taekwondo and
that's kind of funny story too because
my attitude was a bit different and the
taekwondo they practiced in poland at
that time was there's two different type
of taekwondo
itf wtf i so we did the itf there's like
no covering or anything
just go and took it out uh
so we went to the first polish
championship
and i didn't know any better they put
this thing on me i was like how do i
fight with that but okay
so i just keep knocking these guys out
they just keep progressing
so i get every time i finish my fight i
say yes
you have minus points for the being
brutal your fight is brutal you can do
that
so so i mean it was like it was funny
and the final fight
uh final fight for the first place i
knocked the guy out
and there's so the guy's laying there
the guy
that judge comes to me say like you
you're being disqualified
from the program you i mean not quite
disqualified
but he's the winner so then you know
they announced okay this is uh
the winner is saying so right here the
guys are late they're
passed out so i was like okay well
but anyway if i guess it was i was not
very though my fight was not very sports
like because i got a lot of whistles and
booing after
i went this is a second to take my
second place
and then kind of ended up and then you
know the prison came in and uh
actually they helped me a lot in prison
i was i'm glad that uh
i was able to help other political
prisoners as a friend of mine
who actually i met again when i visited
poland recently so
since i didn't have anything to do up
there just sit and
we just just hey you are solidarity i'm
so dirty let's go train
so we were training he said look what
you did to me
help me later survive the beatings that
i got from the guards and the there's
a and all that stuff so
so so you were go let before we get to
being in prison
so now it's the late 70s now at some
point you must you made a decision that
you're not
you're not going to comply with
communism
you're going to you're going to fight
against it yes
the initial i didn't even know how to
but the the
the first thing actually when i when it
would start changing my when when it
started making me aware what's really
going on in poland
was uh i started listening to radio free
europe
and the voice of america and bbc
this station you could go to prison for
listening to it so i remember my mom was
like in panic
oh my god i can hear you get more
pillows on your
over your head get more those big uh uh
uh blanket so neighbors don't hear
that she wasn't fair she could she could
go to prison for that
so uh so i was listening to bbc how old
are you
at that time i think i was 12 13 14.
so so as i was getting all that and i
was getting more interested in what's
going on
this is what i learned that you know the
socialists are
actually quite killing people who are
inconvenient to them
or those people disappear like we don't
know where this guy is
he was very outspoken about socialism he
just disappeared
so so i was learning about it i was
learning also about them the murders the
extra judicial
murders uh committed by judges in poland
who subscribe to socialist ideology
um so that's what started changing uh
in me they say this is not wrong this is
wrong what's what's going on in poland
how did those murders take place
usually you just i tell you how it
could happen because nobody knows but i
tell you what happened to me
eventually so i was working from the gym
we're working out just
do some fights and uh can get the police
pulls in say hey
just grab you by the hands pull in the
car just go that's it and that's it and
then just they drive me and say like
that's like where are we going i said
well where do we go
once we made that it won't anymore
matter to you anything that's like oh
[ __ ]
so i'm already thinking like hey uh so
if we get out of this car i'm going to
kick this guy out
i'm going to do this i'm they're going
to assure me they're going to kill me
most likely but at least i'm not going
to go down quietly
and uh brother just drove around the
town just dropped me off in the
other part of the town i had to walk
back home for a few miles
so that's just like intimidation letting
you know what they can do
yes if they want to yes yes how old are
you and that kind of thing starts
happening uh that started happening
when uh that happened after i was
released from prison
but before that this is what i assume
this is how these people disappear
they don't like you you are outspoken
you cannot we either comply or we just
destroy you or your family
that's that's how socialism works and um
so i experienced that
how they disappear people after i get
out of prison
but before that i was not aware i just
knew that people were just there and
that they were not there any longer
or this they committed suicide or they
followed the stairs
so that some
it was just something that
was waking up in me that this socialist
system
is very oppressive and you can't
leave as a free man when uh
in oppression like this i remember
actually
at that time was also downing on me that
there's different countries they have
differences and they're free
i'll learn about america i remember in
warsaw
first every time i was in warsaw i
always like to go to u.s embassy because
they have those
beautiful cars those big cities there's
those
images you know it's like i can pick
through the fence i can see like whoa
look at this
car you know and then i was like the
images that have all those
like glass things on the fence where we
can read about america
i was like why poland cannot be like
that
you know why this is so awesome i
remember every chance i had
so this is like when when i look at
american flight something like
taking my heart it's like this is so
free
this is this is that this is the freedom
and
i always from then on i always carry so
whenever
something happened in poland i was like
we need to change we need to be like
america
so that's where the start
my views start maturing again so how old
were you when you started to actually
do something about it that you you know
what you eventually get arrested for at
what point
and was it was it other kids was there
some kind of leadership
network of people that were leading
solidarity do you join the solidarity
movement how did what did that look like
it when it crystallized i remember the
first strikes
happened people were hungry i said i
don't know we want food and freedom
so they um they organize strikes this is
where like walesa came in the picture
he was the the prominent eventually
became the leader of
solidarity the trade union movement in
poland so
my mom got involved and i got involved
and i got involved with my friends up
there on the different level my mom was
involved
in school and this is how it went and so
then we start
there was really not much to do at the
time because the solidarity was doing
everything
they were there was the first trade
union there was a trade union
it was the first movement in eastern
bloc country
that was independent from socialist
regime from socialist
communist party so that was uh
you you i was just like i couldn't read
enough
what that was being published what
really happened in 19
when when the communism and socialists
came to poland after the second world
war
on the stallions and bayonets uh
as we started learning you know about
the atrocities about the murders
and about the the the the freedom that
we didn't know that we are not free
sometimes
that but when we learn about how other
countries how is that
it is being done in america so
that's when i started actually maturing
it started growing and
when i 19 so that was right before the
it was before the martial it was late
1970s
when especially with the john
pope came to poland and he like rise
people up he said look
you can live on your knees you need to
rise up you know basically
his message he didn't say it directly
but his message was
like this or was taken this way and
people raised up
and kicked the socialist ass out
so that the they had seen i mean the
communists had seen this kind of thing
happen in
other eastern bloc country countries i
mean
the hungary had happened so they kind of
they follow this so so they they were
nervous about that so they end up
declaring martial law they do martial
law to try and
yes they suppress the the solidarity yes
they lost control they knew it and there
is no way to putting this
genie back i think something will happen
with trump here you can
you can't put it back but unless you're
at least
violence so they realize that they
cannot go back
to what it used to be people won't trust
them people don't trust them they know
they are liar and they know that they
weren't that everybody knew they were
liars
and thieves too so um they
decided eventually we had enough we are
losing control
and if it continues they will hang us
these people hate us really for what we
have what the socialism
done to these people they will
they will prosecute us so they imposed
martial law
and i remember i was on the phone with a
friend of mine he was in austria
and midnight click as we were talking
quiet and say what that what a park that
no uh no connection
so then people start coming hey they
just shut down all the tvs all the
radios
there's no communication though the
telephone lines didn't work they shut
down
the communication the entire poland and
i think 15 after midnight they start
rolling in
so i was at the solidarity headquarters
at the time at midnight
when they came in so they they just
broke the door
they round up everybody who was there
they hold us on the
um on the police station
and then they they only hold those
people who
who hold prominent leadership positions
so
that night they arrested i have
different estimates they are from 25 000
people
on the low side to 65 000 people
arrested
that night they were not criminal
arrests they were there
but basically the way they explain
to us those people are not arrested
they're sitting in jail
but they are interned we internal for
their safety
because we want them to be safe and
also they were potentially dangerous to
the state
so they were not really dangerous they
were there
it's not like they did something they
were potentially
dangerous to the state so we didn't jail
them we just in turn them they have a
good living conditions
we provide them food it's just
it is so ridiculous now when i'm
listening to what i
say and it is so sounds so weird but
that was the fact
then that was that
the way we perceive that reality
that it was quite normal oh well you
know martial are they in
jail 60 000 people one night when you do
something this is why i get to
eventually get
we and a couple of my friends start
building them say we cannot just
see them i didn't watch it we what we're
going to do is sign the shutdown of the
communications
we're going to create our own so we're
going to create our own
network and we start printing
and then just working it was pretty
naive
the way we did that but you know we
didn't know
that i'm any better so we just print
what happened we bring the names of the
uh of people arrested so the families
know that these people just didn't
disappear
yet they're just sitting in prison now
eventually so we stopped
distributing that in in my city where i
was at the time
growing up and that's how it started so
we functioned for a while until we got
caught after and of course it was not
very difficult for them
because they were prepared for that and
um
and that's how i ended up in in prison
eventually they start publishing the
lists of some of the some of the people
they
they in turn basically put them in
presents
so so you get you get arrested they come
to your house do they find you at school
do they find did they
grab you on the street they got me a
pretty much of the street i was working
at the point where we were printing it
to pick up more of the
our newspapers that we printed out and
as soon as i walked in
uh knocked on the door the code we had
the knife and the doors opened exactly
three guys ran up from the upstairs
uh it wasn't like a stairway
uh like five guys jump out of that room
and just put there
i had like 10 guns in my head it was
like a police stand of almost the gun
from
every side pointing loose and uh so
they got handcuffed in the hallway and
get in prison so in in jail and
here goes the netherlands story they
this is something i had no idea i didn't
know that i can have a lawyer
you could but they just ignore that so
it didn't really matter it was
besides it was martial law so that was a
bit different so i got to jail that's
okay so
did you do it i said no did you do it no
you did it no
so you know got a little bit beat up and
uh that
stuck by my thing and no i didn't i
don't know so what about these papers
what did you find in your house because
they went to my house later this
they searched my house my mom later told
me that they just
demolished my house my apartment my home
i mean
i live with my mom that's sort of the
demolished hair apartment like i said i
was just
still kid and uh
so i said well i'll just find them on
the street it's like how you find them
on the street it doesn't really matter
because i get three as present sentence
right off the bat so i remember the
funny thing is like
they uh they got me from uh were going
to the
from the present to to the court so i
took my boots away so he took their
boots i said well i take my boots
so this guy the cop comes out so yeah
this guy kicks so
he cannot run away he cannot kick with
the bad feet i say wow duke with the
bare feet
so they beat me up for that so and i
went to the court i said look i was beat
up i would say like
we don't care that basically i was there
with these judgements to say that we
we don't care it didn't happen so what's
the what's the prison conditions
uh president conditions did for me at
the time i didn't know any better at
that person i thought always has to be
bad
but again you're always hungry right you
have no rights you can't see though
there's another funny thing because
when i went up there they say you can't
you cannot lay down you cannot you have
to just sit
on those stools all day long and just at
the table as i
close a rough table and from the
ultimate just wait there
when that cow comes in you go to uh
you'll go to uh you could lay down in
the bed
so i'm just trying to be you know like
i'm still scared i'm
new to this environment i'm sitting but
it's like [ __ ] i ain't going to sit here
all the goddamn day long
but i'm going to wait and see what will
happen so i'll just lay down just come
and just
kick the [ __ ] out of me if i'm outside
so
i'm coming back to this so i see why now
i'm beat up i can hardly see on my eyes
so i save pocket that
i don't think they're going to beat me
up again now they know i have a
legitimate reason to lay down
i can't see it so another kim did it
again so it's like repeat three times
fine you'd like to say
i guess they say like [ __ ] it they ain't
going to sit and could be laid down so
just left me there
so so i had no problems but then there's
one of those criminal guys because you
would keep
common criminals he'd say [ __ ] ain't
that tough i'm tougher than him so
i think i can earn my way to [ __ ] too
i don't want to sit all day at the table
just on the stool no baggage or anything
so he lay down in bed and he's bad up
there across
and it was my friend it was not my bed
because it was there was like four beds
but it was like
15 of us there so we slept on the frost
but i said like [ __ ] it could
try to kick me out of that so uh so he
lay down on the bed
and the same story just you can hear us
screaming the beating out
he comes back all black and blue and he
doesn't go to bed he goes to the table
and he seems
like he there was a he was like okay
well i had enough
and i will sit so it turns out he wasn't
quite as tough as you
well about toughness i just he yeah he
was not prepared for the beatings
so he was like well i don't really
rather put that with sitting on the
on the stool in front at the table then
then deal with these guys so eventually
they
and actually i was so naive i had no
idea they told me hey
those those those are prisoners like you
know if we can make the hole in this
world to this other self can we have a
sugar and some other food because these
guys have a lot of stuff
so i said [ __ ] i do it you know i'm
just climb under the bed and start
this thing so that made the hole maybe
like this big
but didn't go far because of course you
know there's like there's no no tools or
nothing
wait what were you trying to try to
break the hole in the wall to
using what using using the rug the the
the uh from the stool that you see
okay the like you take them apart and he
took this tool apart
and he had the a concrete legs
yeah it was not it was not really that
hard actually there was not maybe the
concrete in the beginning but eventually
i got to the concrete
but it was so it went went nowhere so
i got pulled out somebody pulled me by
the legs and you know get the good kicks
and
stuff and put out the sound so um so
here it is then um
bag of this this is not the principle
with the word
warden so you have a lot of problems
with you you know you gotta go
you do it again we're gonna go and put
you in isolation
and they kind of like a tiger cage so it
was a cell
and within the cell was a cage just like
in the zoo
and just put you there so i said okay
well whatever i'm not going to be
punching the walls in the
holes in the wall okay because i was so
stupid but
i didn't know any better so then i every
every day for like 15 minutes we were
allowed to go outside and
walk there was like a room maybe a half
size of this
with the high walls with these guards
working on the top above you
and the funny thing is that it was made
of these
concrete posts with the slit inside if
we've seen them in iraq and this
uh reinforced concrete slab will slide
in between the posts one on the top of
another
science well i think that what i
remember i was just for demonstration i
was breaking those in half
so i thought that i heard the voice of
the guy who was in the case with me so
i'm saying to communicate with him
let me take a look i didn't mean to
break that [ __ ] i'll just go
just like get a quick jump and just kick
that [ __ ]
so i thought just making move this some
of this mud from in between those
cracks between these slabs that [ __ ]
thing fell off
and just this whole two slabs above just
fall down on it and stuff you can see
that the alarms going on everywhere i
was like what the [ __ ]
so so i ended up in the thai tiger cage
the town just sitting there and now
there was no there's not the one time
that was the final time but there's the
second the other time
they put me in the prison with uh with
the broken windows it was winter time
and they gave me no blankets so i was
just laying on those woods for uh
i think it was a week so it's not it was
you know
it was was okay i was freezing but there
was nothing that would kill me
and um you know like i'm looking
watching some of the tvs here
about the prison in the united states
i was like [ __ ] now if at that time
i wouldn't tr i would trade my life in
poland for prison here because
i would be fed i have a medical
attention i had a tv
i would have a gym maybe possible even
and
and how can you live better i mean what
else can you do you want from life
because you have you have everything
provided to you you know you don't have
to fight for anything
so that's that's how
so how long we how long did you end up
staying in prison uh there was three
years prison sentence
and they released as i think close to a
year and a half or after a year and a
half
when john paul ii was coming to poland
again so they try to make a gesture so
okay we start releasing political
prisoners for on
amnesty and uh yeah that's
i noticed they started releasing us and
some
the prison starts shrinking because you
know after the case was done my case i
was sentenced to
get my sentence they ship us to russian
border
we were in prison called yeshuf um
basically we can through the window we
can see that the river you can see the
russian territory next
next to it so it's kind of like
unnerving because at that time there was
a reality of uh
invasion i mean we were afraid that the
russians will come in to take
to put some uh uh order there because
they think it was the communism
and socialism was falling apart so they
um
we knew that if the russians come in
we're gonna get killed
so we were thinking like we're going to
get killed anyway if
they come in this is what we need to do
we have like a plans actually you know
how to bridge the
bridge not the bridge like windows other
seals now but how to get through the
wall how to get this we're just making
the
getting the equipment done so they maybe
kill some but maybe they not
don't want to kill everybody but we
cannot just sit here in prison
and just wait for to be slaughtered so
there was that
that that thinking uh at the time
in prison so we uh so yeah so
we were in this uh that's actually a
couple other things came to my mind too
i didn't even think about it
so they beat us up i remember i had some
issues with oh okay
so we went on the hunger strike say okay
when you
where on hunger strike that we we want
status of political
prisoner there was some head of in
socialism i don't know if you guys knew
but
in socialism there are no political
prisoners
the there are but they are sitting for
something else they are sitting like
stealing the milk from the from in from
in front of the somebody's old door
or just insulting the neighbor or just
being mean to somebody so they put you
for something else so they always claim
political prisoners not in socialism uh
we don't have that everybody until the
martial
who was locked up for political
activities
was like that pretty much for something
else for some criminal offenses they
they could generate it
so yeah there was um something that uh
uh when they so they send us the ruby
show that they kind of isolate
the political prisoners there from the
the general criminal population
so it's like pretty much go like and uh
they uh so we decided to go
on the hunger strike and
the way they broke our strike was uh
in poland they say there is a law that
after two weeks if you don't eat
will forcefully feed you so what they
did is like
like a vacuum pipe almost actually
so think i said god damn i ain't gonna
come to my stomach
and so they
put this thing in your throat and they
just put it
the uh whatever the mixture they they
gave you there
and i remember i didn't know it was that
bad but so
i said i'm gonna i'll fight these guys
so i find this today finally they
overpowered me they hang up me to the
chair
but when i tried to put this pipe again
i just broke the [ __ ] chair so they
were fighting they broke that different
chair this time i couldn't break out of
it and they actually
forced it later i learned how to you
know deal with it so
yeah i was like no big deal and just go
ahead stick it put
my my foot in it but the way they broke
it
is typical social is way but a sneaky
so they go to especially the older guys
say look you see this big pipe and
i had to shove it back down your throat
in your stomach again
and and put it in why don't you just
take it yourself
just drink that [ __ ] and go to your cell
so that you're like hmm
that's pretty painful so i just like
okay as soon as you just take a one sip
it's like
wow all right you just broke your hands
right you just ate on your own
so now we're gonna transport you to
another prison the guy never had a
chance the most likely
to go to this prison cell he was just
handcuffed put in the transport and
drove
drove away somewhere so there eventually
there was only a few of us left
and the car came from the church
that this is pointless the the socialist
socialists will never admit they hold
political prisoners
and you just waste your health in to
stop it
so we did eventually we stopped that and
i totally forgot about it until i went
to poland met this guy
he said hey do you remember the hunger
strike here i have the calendar here
this this this
you need to do it's like shitty i
remember now
so how long were you on the 100 hunger
strikes i think it was three weeks
we didn't even before the cal came in to
stop it because they were going nowhere
um yeah
i need to look he gave me that calendar
i don't have it here but uh
to look into it this isn't interesting
actually because uh
the uh there there was things too that
uh
we did in present i can't sing word of
[ __ ] i'm i'm not the singing person
at all but i was singing like a
[ __ ] in presence just like those
political
songs that from polish past from polish
history
they were very patriotic songs which
socialists really hated
so uh we in prison was at eight o'clock
in the in the evening i believe it was
eight o'clock in the evening we just
opened the windows on the whole side
an entire prison population from the
even these criminals still join in
but they get beat up and shut down very
quick and there was there was
they scorched them but not with us so
we kept singing and that was so loud
that that
nearby town they could hear and actually
that priest was coming and praying in
front of the prison
so uh yeah that the guards hated it
because you know
they were they're up have to answer they
beat that people up they throw them and
close the windows up
as soon as they leave their windows got
open again and people are singing in the
south so there's
so much they could do um that that yeah
that was uh
that's fine actually the the i i need to
send that i
send it to you because i have a they
were so bad i guess for them they
i didn't have any family at the time
just my mom so they sent a letter to my
mom complaining say hey
come here and do something your son is
not listening
and actually i was showing to my wife
rachel say look
this look at this here because i knew
that i had that i just couldn't but
then i just by accident i found it so i
had this document saying they're saying
letter from prison to just come out and
help because they
i'm not listening to socialist guards
was there any guards or any government
officials that were like
sympathetic at all or did they just they
just had to toe the party line
uh they had to tell the party line but
there were some of the guards that they
were not so vicious
so they were they they just not
they listened sometimes like there was
even we were able to smuggle the camera
into the present i'm sure that some of
the guards knew about it
and uh there are some pictures floating
i think i've seen some of the pictures
from the prison at the time
and uh some of them like you know on the
christmas time so we had this nerves
say like well can you send us some how
can we
not have alcohol but we have this
alcohol to clean the skin
so i said well let's you know well just
yeah
so just put the rope down
down from the first floor and she she
came out just a
big bottle of this skin cleaning alcohol
just pull it out
you had a party in the present okay can
you get any better than that right
i remember it in communist prison that
was actually it was
really bad if they caught you with this
so you so you end up getting released
when the pope comes back again they do
this gesture
they're going to let you out of prison
right and then are you going
once you're out of prison what are you
doing um
trying to find a job first so i said i
need to do something
i mean my mom cannot she's in a hard
time
she has a hard time too and i cannot be
on her sitting and
living on her from her money so trying
to find a job
and you can't because everything is
controlled the government owns
everything they own the job so if you
i remember after struggling for a while
i still continue my training so
this is what i described earlier after
the training coming out from
sometimes in the evening it depends
wherever we train as police pulled in
they pulled me out the car drive me
around threatened me for a while and
just
threw me on the street so this is when i
said like you know what i can continue
like this
this is something that i eventually end
up dead and
and they did actually we find out later
that uh
later i found out around the same time
that one of the my fellow prisoners
uh was suicided
then another one i was like i'm going to
wait my belong and
then the my images of america came in
yeah so this is where i went and i said
yeah i need to go get some help and uh i
went to uh
american embassy and said this is what's
happening i need help
and hell yeah i was like sure we need
this this this
and within three weeks i had
i think within three weeks i had a visa
out of poland
to germany to the united states per
month the funny thing is
i also had to because i was still in the
age that conscription age
so they uh had to go and sign up like
okay i'm not going to go to
join polish military i'm i'm i'm not
being sold by the military or anything
and i remember i walk into this office
and as i say
i'm leaving poland i need you to sign
this here
so this [ __ ] sergeant just look at me
say you look pretty strong
but you know people like this should
serve poland under this
polish [ __ ] this polish uh symbol
this polish eagle
so you say dude ain't even polish eagle
then [ __ ] you
and your russian's body stole the crown
from that eagle is a bar that
that eagle doesn't have a crown on his
head so that's your eagle but it's not
mine
i'm not serving out of this [ __ ]
right there and
but he already signed this i just left i
remember she says armas
leaving that that building then
[ __ ] was still screaming and
yelling and telling
how bad we are that the bad first people
are
so and i came to to germany uh first in
the little center that the united states
created for us for refugees i'll learn
about america we had people coming
teaching us about america
and eventually i remember still like so
where would you watch do you have any
preferences where you come to america
i remember i was always cold it was out
in poland
i was so cold that maxi we we couldn't
buy the good clothes so my mom put the
newspapers in our
sometimes in our jackets so just like
just don't tell people
don't tell anybody because they're not
be bad on me but uh
just have those newspapers inside will
keep you warm and they did that would
actually
did the trick so i was always cold in
poland and uh
then so
when they asked me i was like well
everywhere
where it's not called i mean if it is
hard it's perfect but just
not where it's called if you can so it's
like what do you think about memphis do
you know anything about memphis it's
like
no but i know that elvis presley was
from memphis i knew that
okay okay so we're looking for the place
in memphis
for you and that's where i came in
that's when i landed in the united
states with the 10 phoenix in my pocket
and bag of clothes
so you so you how long has it been since
you left poland how long were you in
germany for
i was in germany maybe three months are
they
are they teaching you any english there
no there was no time for that there's
mostly like you know the
the legal stuff what you need to do how
you go about
getting the english classes how you
live what is the what the laws are what
how how to be good
a member of society and productive so
there's that we tried to learn on our
own i just remember both myself the
english dictionary
and uh that i lost somewhere on the way
to
where in the in the flight and uh but
that was really good because kosaki
finally even we came from like a normal
world
everything was clean everything was
bright everything was uh
nice people were nice and it's like
that's
that's the world i think that's what
america is going to be doing so
really i was really excited just to to
you know to come to america at the time
what year is it it's 1984 beginning it
was
i left 1983 like december 1983 and this
is like beginning 1984.
so you you get on a plane are you by
yourself or is there other people with
you there were some other people with me
uh there was uh those group of people
refugees from the communist
social estate and uh but we were going
to different locations so some of them
were i didn't even know
and once we get on this big jumbo jet it
was like
i didn't even know who these people were
where they went so i
uh eventually i landed in new york
and i remember i just wanted to see this
statue of
like so great you know and uh
yeah is anyone escorting you
is anyone oh yeah yeah i mean it was
like we didn't come on our own i mean
when we came in there was part of the
people waiting for us everything was
provided that's they
they help us to our destination memphis
i remember this where i got my first
apartment
to they helped me get the apartment my
first job
and uh i was so excited i remember i i
never knew what the air conditioning is
right
so i was watching the movies from
america in poland when i was young and i
see those boxes in the windows
i thought they're just a boxer you can
put the milk inside you know food
because in poland it's so cold
you just put outside the window your
food your mail your stuff i say
this is so cool they are so smart you
know why in poland don't have this we
could have this box behind the window we
could put more stuff in it
and then but then there's always land
there's actually there's not the boxes
for food it's just air conditioning so
this one that keeps your
house cool and and healthy and but i
remember
so when i moved to my first apartment i
couldn't contain myself
tell my mom say i call my mom say mom
i'm living in the apartment and with
climatization with air conditioning
she's like what air conditioning i say
it blows cold air if on demand if you
want
say oh my god how much do you pay for it
can you afford these things
i say no yeah it comes with apartments
so yeah there was so uh i mean that that
that
that change was so drastic i remember
going to the store first time
grocery store in poland was very simple
just grab whatever was left on the shelf
and just run with it before somebody
grabbed it from you it's like
here you walk you see the cereal first i
didn't know what the cereal was
like what's this oh this is like a
cereal like this i don't know what it is
but i take one
but then you look at these boxes they're
also looking cool so nice it's like
we'll try this one maybe i try this one
so i have like 50 boxes
then it was so the abundance
of everything something i could not get
used to it for a long time
i always end up by trying to buy maybe
like five six dollars groceries
i end up like thirty forty dollars
another damn
spend all the money again because my
first paycheck was i think was like you
know forty dollars a week
so i remember but
of course people i wouldn't be able to
make it without americans helping me
so they uh i remember this 40 dollars
usually by the end of the week because i
had to save money to pay for apartment
it was like 108 dollars i think for
apartment
electricity and everything uh i had
maybe like
i ran out of money at the end of it so i
just have to wait for my paycheck
as soon as i get the paycheck it's more
cereal more food you know people are
bringing me food too
so um again i would not survive in north
americans
helping me who is that who were the
americans that were helping you was it a
religious group
there was a religious group saint grace
look church in memphis
and these people are
a christians and they
how they help so many people and i think
i feel obligated i need to do something
to maybe
reciprocate it now kind of late
but uh those are awesome people
and they are they're still there they
still actively support
people coming to america help them
settle down i would never succeed
if not their help i was very lucky
the funny thing is too that i didn't
speak english so
they bought me a dictionary and
and so i'm just trying to learn as much
as i can i remember one day this
one of the families like older couple
older couple
pick me up and say hey we're gonna drive
you here today show you these are the
main things and this
so as we drive actually this is them
they gave me the dictionary
so uh because they're like they were
helping us it was just that couple words
maybe i think it was like designated to
help us
so the immediate dictionary actually i'm
trying to show that i'm using
it and i'm really trying to learn and i
see this black guy walking on the street
so i'm looking dictionary to say this is
black man right so just look and say
and the addiction that it says this is
n so i say hey this isn't
it it was like tim will crash the car oh
my god no no dude
why do you say that would you learn the
word i say the
dictionary you gave me right here so i
have the dictionary here today with
this lady still scratch that word and
say
black man you know i didn't know any
better i mean for me
i grew up in poland there was no no
there was just only white people there
so i didn't even know about the animals
how animals it is when we the first
black person i've seen i was maybe like
16 17 years old i said this is so
freaking cool i never seen guy with its
color of the skin
so me and my brothers were like circling
around this guy i'm sure this guy said
what the [ __ ] weirdos
but we were like holy [ __ ] he's really
black you know
i didn't know it but there was never any
sinister feelings it was just
curiosity and i said i want to be
friends with them you know let's invite
these guys to our club you know and
actually we did that they show up
so given the polish names one was yashu
and one was
something else and uh we became friends
you know so but it was the first black
people i've seen so
so do you go to any classes to learn to
speak english or is it just working no
no at the time i was working already so
for
they the church providers like short
menu i think it was a one month class
of english where we attend you know
let's have to learn
was it hard was it hard to learn it was
hard for me
uh as you can hear it now 30 years later
but
uh yes that was uh it gives us some
basics maybe
but i remember you know like
pronunciation good god that was killing
me
uh thank you there is no th word in
polish so thank you for me to say it was
like
i couldn't i could just could not say it
i was spitting i was just
butchering the word probably friend of
mine comes in and say hey
just you know [ __ ] it just say thank you
very quick say f instead of
ph they won't even hear the difference
if you say it fast
so sure i did you know and i said i
remember some meetings somewhere where
this uh
i think there's a priest or somebody who
brought the cookies so i grabbed the
cookie and as i tried to struggle with
this
should i say this guy from behind like
thank you so it's like look it's like
[ __ ] you you know
it was like get quiet it was like that's
not right
they say something wrong this guy like
disappeared behind it's like
and finally one of the older gentlemen
comes in what he is trying to say
is and he looks at me and say thank you
thank you you know i work on it hard
that's so i'm better
now but i'm still like you know that's
my wife and there are words that i'm not
allowed
to say in public so like sometimes like
hey take my phone can you put the phone
in your puss
it's like don't ever say that loud in
front of anybody that's just
say say my my my bag or something so
it's challenging for you to say
purse puss okay yeah
like a little list of words that i'm not
allowed to say especially around my wife
so i'm because i'm doing that so what
was the first
actual job that you got once you're
on the ground you're in memphis you got
a you got an apartment it has
air conditioning yeah what's the first
the actual job this job was in the
dealer it wasn't
church i was basically mopping the
church cleaning the toilets
and there was something to get me
through getting me familiarized a little
bit with
with america with get with english
behind my belt and so basically i was
working part-time
as a janitor and this is where actually
i start actually picking up
english more irma had a bucket
map in one hand and i have a little
cartoon
cartoon in my back pocket so and joey is
going to
the store and joe is going to the store
joe is going to the store it means that
he is going to go and buy some groceries
basically in polish so i was translating
it and
so i did more cartoons i was picking up
even more and more english and
eventually i think they decided i'm good
enough to
venture find like a different job
so the church helped me to get the job
with oakley kizzy ford
uh first time in memphis and i was
oakley key z forward yes okay that
sounded like a polish word actually
especially when i had to translate
polish to english and black so uh
in iraq but um so i got the job up there
my job was to pick up the
uh the phone and they already knew that
there's a guy who doesn't speak english
but he knows the numbers
so they say okay five six six
seven eight nine ten so i'll just write
it down
i say thank you click i ran upstairs and
i picked the part there was five five
six seven eight and brought it up
so the the the the the cars from
different dealerships or whoever needed
that part
was coming into the door and picking
picking it up and
i was just the guy who just take the
phone call get the number get the parts
i was working really hard but got them
those numbers i just kept mixing up so
those guys coming up and like two hours
later here
[ __ ] we just got the wrong part
that's not the part we wanted to the
mechanic says that
we just gave him a wrong part so they
come to me it's like hey you know then
we are you're working so hard we see it
we don't want to fire you but
you know you just need to get better but
do you know anything about cars european
cars maybe
i was like yeah you know i have an idea
but yeah yeah
because there is an opening in another
dealership and they are looking for
uh mechanics for saab porsche and audi
maybe i don't know if you would want to
go and
try that too you know that's i say yeah
absolutely yes so yeah
i know all the everything about cars how
many people when you were in poland how
many people did you
actually know that actually owned their
own car
i personally didn't know anybody who
owns the car i know some people who knew
some people who were the guy
and now you're okay so you're a car
accident my father because he was a
communist
he he was allowed he owned the car there
you go
so that was the expertise that i had
i know somebody who who knew somebody
with the car
uh so so i went for the interview and it
was like my english was
so broke i hadn't like even i didn't
know what i was saying
but i remember that the that so they
brought they was like
they needed a mechanic for porsche audi
and saab
and uh so they brought the the foreman
from the porch first he'll he looked at
me like
and i know there's like blah blah blah
which is like that
we can't have a guy guy doesn't even
speak english so the the audi mechanic
came in he talked to me
for a while and i tried to say my best
but he's like i can see him kind of
heads and now
and then the sub mechanic comes again
this big
guy like motorcycle gangster and walks
in she's like
looks at me i take him my slave
come with me as i started my career i
became good i became good
this guy i owe him so much
uh he as he was he was running without
the motorcycle gangs and uh
he uh i remember he was very proud
guy and and
but i was able to actually talk him into
look
at jimbo carson jimbo look jimbo i can't
speak english very well
i need to learn this thing i have these
manuals for saab
if you can read it loud to me
i can record it i can listen at home and
i can match the words with the recording
i thought he would kill me first time
say [ __ ] i ain't reading [ __ ] i
don't even know how to read well
but then then
i talk him into it and he says so we're
sitting in his uh
kitchen he'll keep he kept reading that
manuals and it was
i know that was hard for him i could see
it i could tell it was hard for him
but he did it for me so uh we become
like really good friends and very often
you know he came back drawing up there
laying in the car
so say hey jim are you working i say
yeah he's working right here i'm just
helping him out right there
so he's like okay if somebody comes in
just kick me i'm going to sleep and say
okay
he's sleeping great guy
actually this is the first time that i
was exposed to american american way of
eating too because
so i remember saying you know him to
come over here
uh we'll have a stakes and i'll just
we'll just have a stakes and say okay so
i show up and
uh there's a big ass i think two stakes
no three states with his girlfriend
there
so there's big ass three stakes are like
[ __ ] we're gonna be eating it for a
month
i mean so like so who who else is coming
here
he said no just three of us i said what
about the stakes
yeah you can have one i mean the one is
for you here you can pick whatever you
want
i was like i mean that entire steak you
say yeah
what's wrong with that i said dude i'll
be slicing it and slicing it just so
that thing would last me for a month in
poland and i
i just didn't know that you can eat just
steak like that just by the slab of meat
you cook it and you eat it that's like
what the [ __ ] and
i love steaks i'm addicted to steaks now
so
so that was i was exposed first time
it's like yeah you eat the steak you eat
the steak you don't
you don't just paper slice it like this
and because in poland you know it was
i didn't mention that i just come back
very quick to it the
the socialism what did to poland is that
once became
very resilient to hunger because i i was
going hungry to school
quite often because my mom you had to
you cannot buy food for more than two
three
three four days especially bread or
something so
if my mom didn't get up early enough
around 3 o'clock 3 30 4 o'clock in the
morning and stay in line which is
sometimes around the block uh to buy a
loaf of bread
i think i had no breakfast so sometimes
she was in a lie alright for a couple
hours but then
they sold out bread before she could get
it i was hanging to school
going to school but my remedy for it was
i just find out those are richer kids
from those especially those parties
party members sons they have always food
they have really good food
so i just beat them up and i took their
flange and i i
i ate their lunch and i said like you
want to eat lunch you break two
sandwiches next time
so i had so much supply that i actually
i was like robin hood because i was like
the poor
guys that i knew up there and i was like
okay you bring the sandwich to this guy
you bring this out to this guy and you
to me and if they didn't we just took
their lunch and we just ate their lunch
and then
they usually they brought their lunches
so how long are you working at the uh
what was it the saab dealer it decided i
worked for quite a few years
and uh i think it was to the point that
the war
then i became u.s citizen too so for me
it was it is still it is the biggest
accomplishment
for me people think you made to the
serial training how does it feel about
it well
tell you how does it feel to be american
citizen i tell you how to be american
i'm a free man
that's the biggest accomplishment on me
that's not the seal teams i'm very proud
of the
of the trident i'm very proud what i did
in the seal teams but
it is not my biggest accomplishment
i always look in this american flag
and i'm american i'm not polish american
i'm not
something american there is no hyphen in
front of this american i am an american
and i'm proud
and uh so yeah that's
so you mentioned um you mentioned the
first gulf war
but then you at what point because i
know you got into parachuting at some
point oh yeah well
how did that happen yeah i was i was at
the time uh i said well
i met the girl who made the parachute
jump
she told me well you know it's like you
need to try it at least once i say [ __ ]
i tried it once
that was before the war before anything
so i say well i just called the drops
and i said hey can i make a parachute
jump
said sure come on over that was in
memphis so i came and said how can i
make the parachute jam well you have to
see through the classes will be tandem
jump i say tandem jump okay
so i sit for the class you know that he
explained you what to expect what to
look
we end up and jump [ __ ] i was hooked
so i was like can i do it again it was
pretty expensive
but you know being single at the times i
yeah you can do it again so i do one
more time so like
can i jump by myself like not right away
but you
have to go to the classes so tell me
about it so
here's well so you got you have a class
most likely like on the weekend then
monday you come you do one job maybe two
jumps tuesday wednesday night within two
weeks you get this
enough just seven jobs because aff
accelerated free fall at the time and uh
so you made enough jobs then you can
graduate to jump on your own
i say [ __ ] where can we start i say
we can start actually this thursday
i say no friday i say okay
so friday i came i had all the classes
we made the three jumps saturday i made
the next four jumps
and i was i think saturday evening i was
jumping on my own so it took me
three days i was hooked so yeah i was
skydiving actually this is funny because
uh
in memphis we jump from very high out
into usually twelve thousand feet
sometimes from fifteen sixteen thousand
feet so so though i had a
i accumulated a lot of free fall at the
time so i decided to go myself for the
aff jum master course i said i become
the drum master i will be teaching
skydiving
and i did and actually i did extremely
well
i remember when in terms of oklahoma at
the time the only issue i had again with
my language because uh
you know it's you have to do class
you have to do class you have to be very
thorough if you miss
something the instructors usually
there's the uspa commission
people there's very experienced sky
divers they pick up what you miss in the
brief
and they did that errors in the air
which you didn't believe or you you said
it the wrong way
you taught it the wrong way so we had an
agreement we were always partnerable so
with one of the guys and we had the
agreement you know if i ask you
the question you answer it correctly so
i don't have to because if you answer
them correctly i have to reteach you
because these people are watching if i
don't
catch your error or your wrong answer
then they will go and do it to me in the
air
so we we are okay so we're up with that
agreement
and you know there is a point in the
skydiving tour and we teach people
eventually say like
so there is a attitude that you have to
make your decision either cut away the
malfunctioning parachute if you have
malfunction
and open the reserve or you ride it the
ground
certainly that time was 2 000 feet you
should buy 2 000 feet you don't have a
good parachute
and you need to make the decision to cut
away as a new jumper and
and and open your reserve if you didn't
do it by this time was like you just
should be riding it to the ground
so we go through it and say i look at
this guy and this commission is
listening there and
so okay now uh tell me what is your
heart dick
this guy looks at me so like what i was
like you know tell me about your heart
dick
i see i can't tell that so now i'm
getting amanda's like
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] with me what's
your heart dick
and uh he says what do you mean
what do you mean i said you know the 2
000 food hard dick
i don't have 2 000 foot hard dick
i was like i was like about to punch
this guy i look up there and this hole
is that
they're laying under the table they're
[ __ ] so hard i was so focused that
you know
it's a two thousand foot hard deck yeah
yeah
for me it's kind of like insane same
thing
so so he didn't tell he said nothing
about two thousand foot hard dick but uh
eventually i agree yeah and but i
graduate from this course
even regardless this hard dick and uh
yeah
so uh i was skydiving by this time
but but it seems like
coming from poland coming from not
having food from being in prison from
all these things that are going on
it seems like when you get to america
you've just got this
this like drive just to live and make
things happen and you're going to free
fall and you get it done in four days
and then i'm going to become a jump
master and you're working as hard as you
can
it's like you have this open freeway in
front of you
you can be whatever you are able to be
you know i can't say whatever you want
to be
because i want to be astronaut i'm 60
years old i ain't going to be
astronomical with me but
but but you can be whatever you are able
to be there is
nothing to stop you like different
countries you are what's your
background who is your mom did you do
are you communist or are you belong to
socialist party
so we can help you but if you know you
cannot be in these positions you cannot
go to
to college even if you don't have if you
are not part of the socialist youth
organization so so for me yeah it was
like the entire world open i could be
whatever i was able to be and
there was nothing stopping me so even
more
even more makes me uh that
stick to my word i want to be the best
citizens i want to make this country the
best it can be
and and contribute to it so that's where
the first
person work him out and i just became
u.s citizen at the time
so i was like okay
i can't build the jobs for these people
i'm not the rich enough i don't have
resources but i can fight for them so
this is my country i'm going to go
and sign up i had no idea how to do it i
remember in post
views i seen those draft cards sometimes
that you you fill it up so i say
i went up there i fill it up i send it
out i packed my [ __ ] i was living with
other sky divers at the time
so they said what what's going on dragon
where are you going i say i'm going to
i just send out my papers and this is
this is the first goal for the first
goal right so it's 1991
yes the first gulf war kicks off yes you
want to go fight i don't so you go down
to the post office
grab the uh what's that thing called the
the selective series
yeah yeah you filled that out i might
shake your bags
and that's right any time now
so well nothing happens the guy's like
drago you know i don't think that's the
right way to do it
but you you sure you want to go into war
man there's a war going on up there
i say yeah yeah i mean you have to help
this
i came here with nothing and everything
i have i own to
america to this country i need to do
something
and the best way i can do is going to
fight for my country
so yeah that's uh i'm waiting on the
event they simulated
sorry but this selective service doesn't
apply to you you're too old
so i was already 31 at the time going 32
and so i say
i find my i will find my way into that
war
so somebody said hey why don't you go to
recruiting of recruiting office
as a sure i went to the uh
army for in poland army is everything
yes this is like army are you talking
about army air forces
for me at that time was everything was
army so good to army
okay this is me i would like to join
military i would like to go to war
it's like okay what do you want to do or
say
a fight there's like no no we're like at
jobs or something you have any skills
i say um no not really but
i would doubt do whatever you tell me to
do you know i just want to go to war
hour when the war is over i will go back
to my normal life but i
i think just for the duration of the war
i would like to join the military
they say okay well let me see or they
look at my documents
they tell me what to bring so i bring
all that stuff they did all the
all the work say so okay so we put you
as a infantryman i think it was
infantryman and style and
i say absolutely thank you so much i'm
ready to go anytime
and then as seals show up
in our drop zone they were doing
demonstration jump
leapfrogs in in memphis so we started
talking about it
we jump few times together and say
they're such a cool guys you know
and uh so they um yeah it's like
but you know before they join the army
why don't you try the navy
just go ask recruiters about seals
i was like seals what's the seals yeah
but the navy
these cool guys knows i'm jumping they
call themselves seals so i'll just go
and ask hey
i went the next door i said i'm applying
here for army
and they have all my paperwork but i met
some friends who told me to ask about
the navy and the
i'm just asking about the navy who those
friends are saying they're
current themselves seals oh
yeah yeah you know you can be a ceo
it's like but i didn't get those
paperwork from these guys
we put you in the navy and
you're okay then then we'll just put you
in the navy you will be a seal then
i say okay so i went down next door
i'm going there so can i have it they
were pissed they did not like it but so
anyway i got my paperwork i show up up
there and they look through my papers
and they're like eventually well you
know what we can guarantee you the zero
that dice there was a different program
at the time
we cannot guarantee to you because you
are way too old you are even too old to
qualify for the sales but
if you sign this paper here you join you
go to bootcamp
they will make you zero that's not no
doubt about it oh yeah
so i said sure you know that's enough
i say okay but they said but now before
you become a ceo
you need to get a job you can select the
job in the navy at that time there was
no cl rating you remember that there was
a
you you go to bootcamp you get a go to a
school get the job in the navy and then
you go to if you like you you are
assigned to go to seal training
so i said well i don't know much what i
want to do i'm parachuting something
with
how about being parachute regular cause
it sounds good to me
i had no idea what it was it stuck me in
this field for like as an e5 for years
later but
i said like okay so yeah absolutely yeah
make me serious and make me a
at that time i was dating a girl too so
they say okay but if you want to go to
that school to pr school
uh you will have to leave this week you
will have to leave on a
thursday we'll put you in the delay
entry program
and i think you'll be sworn on thursday
you will leave on friday i believe
that's i think it was like
sure notice so i called my girlfriend
hey we need to get murdered right now
because i'm going to the navy i'm
just like what i said i'm leaving to the
navy i'm leaving this for this weekend
so we went to the judge we got like the
stem we got married very quick and uh
then i show up on the in that got the uh
sworn in
and thursday i left to boot camp and
didn't become
that there was like no intention to make
me a ceo but you know for that time i
didn't really care
i just wanted to join military i want to
contribute to the effort
i am american i want to fight for my
country
so whether being the parachute trigger
whatever i just made the best out of it
by the size the opportunity shows up i
said why not to be a seal i want
i try it and i did i passed all the
tests so that was
in boot camp and both they do that they
do that day where they go okay if you
want to try for seals you need to go
take the test right now yeah there's a
there's like a day that
actually they're different jobs i think
there's people that are coming and
telling about their jobs
so there are sales eod motivators show
up and he talked about i just couldn't
sit in this
[ __ ] chat just get out just
hey yeah yeah i want to go um
so and now you're are you 32 years old
at this point at this point 32 years old
i think what the f what the hell kind of
physical conditioning did you do
throughout your life to get to get there
and be in like good enough shape because
they don't even let guys go to buds when
they're
27 or 28 or something i don't know i
guess i got to beat up a lot
i just got conditioned did you did you
work were you working out this whole
time
not really i didn't know how i didn't
know that the physical
demands of the seal teams at the time
are just like
just what about just in life like in
like when you were
when you were working in that freaking
side kickboxing taekwondo yeah that's
that's that was just basically what
you're a mutant you're a freaking mutant
well i just can't consider myself lucky
that you know i was able to
the and you know the test is really not
that difficult to pass
yeah there is still it's still something
but yeah
preparing but yeah so so so just so
people know what you're talking about
you say the test isn't that hard to pass
the bait the seal test that we used to
get to get a
chance to go to seal training was like
i think it was you had to do it's some
minuscule it's like
50 push-ups in two minutes 50 sit-ups in
two minutes
yeah eleven eight pull-ups ten pull-ups
eleven eleven pull-ups
and then a mile and a half run in 11
30 and a mile and a 500 yard swim in
yeah
yeah or something like that my struggle
was with the swim which i couldn't swim
very well so
uh but i took it i got it you know
i passed it so i'm so happy i'm like oh
yeah this is so cool
and then i [ __ ] got the kidney stone
a kidney stone yeah well that's right
because you're a freaking old man yeah
yeah yeah yeah so the kidney stone and
that
and i remember they that was so
freaking painful i mean i never wasn't i
was never beat up so hard it was so
painful
like this but uh that was so painful
that i remember they gave me that
medicine
i think it was demoral it's like didn't
work at all i said i need something
stronger
because i i just i'm i'm
i'm about to go crazy i'm okay that pain
is so so hot so they give me a morphine
just like it went away but i remember
this funny thing because the first time
with this show i had no idea what it was
i was lying in the bunk
in the boot camp and that's just this
pain came in i just fell off the bed
and so they turned the lights on and
within like three minutes i had this
pool of sweat right under my nose all
dripping i'm on my force
this medic comes and says hey are you
okay it's like [ __ ] do i look a cave to
you
can't move i say so they got me the
hospital i passed it but
that was not the worst thing there was
things they told me well you know you're
going through this medical thing we're
about to give you the medical
examination
for sales but you had just had a kidney
stone you have to wait the air
i was like [ __ ] but you know my mindset
was
i want to fight the war in any capacity
you know i'm
i'm honored that i have that privilege
to go and fight for america
so for me this really matters so i said
that's that's okay
and so then i went to a school and the a
school i met
uh resident peace uh less barrios
i don't know if you knew him but so les
barrios uh
he was a motivator in millington when i
was going to the my parish dragon school
i said look
i passed the test i think i can easy
past it again
but i had this kidney stone and i cannot
i just want to be a seal so
it's in a way maybe there's some maybe
paperwork can be done
if you just say a paperwork yeah i think
you can just go get your medical record
from your
your medical office bring it here we'll
take a look at it
so i ran up there and said what magic
you will come up with i'm sure there's
some
paragraph or some regulation that will
allow bypass the stupid kidney stone
so i brought this record and i said
that's right
right there right there and it's like
okay i just i want you to leave the room
here i'll be
i'll just call you in a second and i
could hear rip
so he comes back so the kidney stone
uh where is that i was like right
oh so he likes i don't see any
i said i don't see any either you sure
he had the kidney stone
it's like you know maybe not
maybe i didn't okay well he didn't so
and i graduated from a school in
millington i think we're under the
second top
you know everything that from bootcamp i
graduated top recruit in this whole
batch i was there
i got a military excellence award i was
like a first very first recruit
actually uh who the top recruit from
that badge
graduating high school i graduated the
second
with the second highest score so i i had
things going on for me and then i was
waiting for
my orders he said okay i send it out for
it hopefully it gets approved
and sure three months later got my
orders too bad
so that that's the rest of this rest of
it is a history
you show up at buds what was uh
what was there any major challenges for
you was like you said you were not
not a great swimmer how were you on the
rest of the water stuff well
the the the the problem was that i could
swim only on one side and i never swim
with the mask on
so you know they dump me in the pool and
say i want you to swim here there's a
side stroke
side stroke this is how you do it and
but you'll be swimming all the styles
that will tell you to do
it and i was kind of okay with it but
when they push them put the mask on
after the first couple laps i thought it
would pass out i mean i was like
hyperventilating i was blacking out
i see the black spots in front of myself
i'm about to die here
but i said like if i stop they kick me
out so i ain't stopping i say i know
that
if i pass out they will rescue me that's
those guys everywhere they tell us that
we are safe so we are safe
so you know i was blacking out like
fell about to black out having these
black spots but it became easier
and easier but i think by the time like
the next hour i was like
[ __ ] they ain't that bad so what is it
just like some weird like claustrophobic
thing on your face or something
like that no i couldn't breathe through
my nose and i couldn't breathe now how
to breathe through my every time i to
get breath i've sucked
water with it so i think i i was
breathing water and air at the time and
i was coughing i was
suffocating i was i was basically
drowning i felt like i'm drowning and uh
it's just i said i'm not going to quit
but i'll just
pass out and see what will happen if i
have to but i didn't pass out and
i got better actually by the time there
was a fourth phase there was a pre-phase
when
before you class up for the uh for the
serial training
so by the time we graduate from the
fourth phase move into our
single class the instructors asked me to
demonstrate the new guys how to swim the
side strokes so
i became really good i was never a fat
swimmer but i was strong swimmer i could
swim forever and you didn't you didn't
come up with any injuries or anything
being a 33 year old guy going through
buds uh not at that time uh
the the worst thing else was always
tired i was looking this young guys like
hey let's go to the bar
it was like dude i can hardly move i
can't go to the bar
i'll still make it out to the bar here
and there but that was just like
really painful for me because uh again i
was not the intensity of it it's not
just the one time
it was like one time like the seal
training i think most of the people that
one day can check out
he may survive but it over and over and
over it just wears your body wears you
down
and eventually some people quit so that
was the most difficult for me because
i did not recover as fast being 32 years
old
as uh as other guys so what was your
first
what were your first orders what team
did you get i get to see all team two
and uh actually they they uh i wanted to
go to sealed in four because they
i don't want to be called i know clt two
at them at the time operate the
the north part and the of the europe and
in europe in general
so i say i just want to go to like team
four but friend of mine said like no no
dude
you with your language with your polish
russian and you
i speak japanese too so uh with with
your languages
you'll be good asset in this uh european
team and stuff
so i kind of like put the so i switched
it from the
team four to team two and put them for
second and just like that please
don't put me in sdv's
i just for some reason i don't know i
was i was not maybe that technical
person at the time
and the challenge is to be uh as the
operator is twice as it is twice
you have to be a seal but you have to
have that expertise
with this mini subs and with the the
operation of it
that for me i felt was overwhelmed by
that what you need to know to be good
operator in the sdv teams
so um so i i chose two and i got my
orders to see our team too
went to boot uh went to jam school uh
did you did you go to fort benning yes
for me it was kind of fun time because
uh you know like when i was growing up i
was poor i never had a chance to go to
like a disneyland or
this type of thing i could watch over
the fence how children were playing
around it but
i couldn't afford it so when i got into
this tower i was like holy [ __ ] this is
like a disneyland you know
so i didn't care what the position he
wanted me to jump but i just like
running out of it
and and yeah that's uh
they kind of didn't like it but they uh
but they are very rigid
so i remember two of those that i had a
lot of fun too because those
i think you went through the same thing
yeah so there is a dress
for being so you still next to each
other shoulder shoulders so close
that basically usually cannot even move
and then you just go to your line you
grab the line they drag you just
do the plf i could never do the plf
right i was always scared of plfs
so uh but anyway i found out that if you
like tip one of them from one end
it's like a domino effect they would
just totally fall down
and that was actually i thought it was
amazing it was amusing
it's like that's pretty good you tip one
a little bit and the last guy just
plugs down um my but my issue was that
i don't like prfs so
so just so everyone knows a plf is a
parachute landing fall
and it's a technique that you get taught
for static line jumping
where it's supposed to minimize your
injuries
because you keep your feet and knees
together and you
hit like you kind of like roll you sort
of roll when you hit
and you keep your arms kind of tucked in
and
it's supposed to prevent you from
getting injured because when you're on a
when you're on one of those parachutes
you're still coming down really fast
it's not like
what you see in the movies when guys can
kind of come down on a free-fall
parachute and they flare and they just
kind of
kind of tiptoe away from it you hit
pretty hard especially if you're a
heavier guy the heavier you are the
harder you're going to hit
so they try and teach and plus the
army's working with
hundreds and hundreds of people getting
thrown out of that thing getting thrown
out of an aircraft every day
so they try and teach the most simple
way that they can teach
hundreds and hundreds of of people how
to fall without getting hurt
now i also was not good at the plf
yeah scoot the [ __ ] out of me so i
actually i tried one time and just
popped my shoulder and i like
[ __ ] doing it more so every time i
jump i just stood up i just
but it was not a big deal because i
actually had hundreds of giants at the
time so
i just jumped out just really landed
just stand up and i was like
so it's like there's they had those
those black black hats they had those
cubes plf private pli of plf i want to
see pmy i was like
roger there then i might throw my
parachute and just roll on the ground
you know they don't hurt i didn't want
to come over
so so that they they knew from me from
not listening too good
uh yeah those pls they were killing me
so i didn't do them
so you get to team two and what what uh
did you get put in a platoon right away
did you go through sqt first no
i had to wait for sqt i had to wait for
st though at that time it was sdt
uh serial tactical training but uh when
i show up in the teams you know
like you you are the new new sailor i
was a new seller everywhere i want the
bootcamp
to a school or you know the bots
everywhere so formal so uh so you know i
buy the book and everything so
i show up and buy like i don't even know
like five minutes later i'm hanging on
the pull-up body my blues and the
[ __ ] doing pull-ups
running three miles [ __ ] that i do my
prt in my thing
and uh and it's like what the [ __ ] by
the time i even
you know realize what's going on i had
like completed the whole prt
in my blues and stuff so they were just
like with the new guys yeah just sure
so what he's talking about there is he
shows up
at in his dress uniform when you check
into a new command you're in your dress
uniform it's the nicest uniform you've
got
and you don't you know normally you'd
wear it for like a ceremony
so he shows up with that uniform on and
they're like cool we're going to do a
physical
uh physical what is it prt or something
let's see r
physical readiness test yeah so you've
got to take a physical readiness test
the event tell me that hey they say get
on the pull up yeah do the pull-ups okay
go for the run now push-ups
everything was so shiny you know i spent
all night just making
sure that there's no no wrinkles no
nothing and here i am there's all this
ragged up so anyway i finished that
that's the welcome to it welcome to the
teams new guy uh
yeah but you know i just i said that
that's okay i guess this is the
the way it goes i roll with it
and the the another surprise for me was
uh
very much so we came in there's a couple
other new guys at the same time
so when we show up in the team and they
say hey hey guys at that time in the in
the teams on every friday
we had the kegger in the highway so it's
a keg of beer and
the guys were drinking beer so hey we
new guys we just invite you for the
kreger you know just
i'm sorry you need to come and join us
for the for the so i remember i was so
taken
like these old guys these old navy seals
they are so cool you know like these new
guys they
invite for the beer and stuff and well i
didn't know that were there just for the
amusement of these all new guys then as
soon as
that not sooner than we just crossed the
door of this bay we just get beat up
taped up hang up in there on those
[ __ ] chains up hanging like a bats
while these guys guys are drinking beer
and just throwing the insults on
us and stuff say hey you know it's like
once i have to be fair once every while
they lower us down they stick this
tube in our mouth from the dragon just
pull the dragon into the
uh beer in the dragon bag and just
squeeze it as fast as you can
so by the time you are drinking so much
beer that you didn't care if you hang
you upside down or not
as long as they didn't leave you
overnight hanging and that it didn't
happen so
so now i realize that this is that we
are not there to just
uh fraternize how to say it to rather
nice
fraternize with the old seals we are
just there for the amusements and you
guys
they call us meat you know [ __ ] new
guy
so that's uh yeah that was the welcome
to the team so but you know that's it
i look at it figure out that's the way
it goes so i
i don't have a problem with that and i
was waiting for my st getting beat up
here and there and then
and then that was fine and then we got
to st
at sdt pretty much pretty
straightforward
pretty straightforward but with me that
was like there's me and another guy
scotty lanton a great guy i love this
guy
um he led the teams later but uh
so those two of us that were a bit
different i remember so we went through
st
everything went a little bit problem
with my english because i still have to
translate everything all the commands
you you you shouldn't move and you you
know you communicate so far
that's going to translate in my head in
polish then and
be fast enough to do it and react to it
so
it was okay so when they eventually came
to the crypto and the
the the radio communication equipment
there's you know the communication
class and we went to crypto and we were
sitting there by the time we were about
to take a test
from this as i was like like two more
days so the so today was the last class
you know how to use the cryptographic
equipment how to use all that stuff
and um so that the next day supposed to
be
i think a final exam and then there's a
then move to the next section of sdt so
this guy comes in and one of the
instructors comes in is like hey
do you have a clearance it's like
i don't know what it is so most likely
you don't have it do you have a
clearance
and scared like well i'm not even u.s
citizen
wow come on with me you know so we went
up there and said like
so like look at us like don't ever say
anybody that you went through this class
you just don't say nothing don't say
anything
you you never sit in that class it's
like okay
you guys get your clearances then go we
will do it
and uh so so yeah we just see that so
next day we see our guys watching
running through the field you know with
the equipment setting it up you know
doing the crypto stuff and and i was
watching it i was like
[ __ ] i mean there's nothing difficult i
could pass the test now science already
already went through all this class i
don't know it's a big deal but
i guess they don't want us they don't
want anybody to know that we sat through
that class
not having the secret clearance and uh
and so you know i eventually got my
clearance so i went to the radio shack
upstairs in the sealed him too and
passed the test
as scott linton eventually got his
citizenship so we all went whole
platinum went up there and just using
the platinum by this time
and he got his crypto stuff too and uh
we moved on
so that my first platoon is i was
remembering bixler good god i think
if this guy didn't have a heart attack
he had i think he might he will have it
because of me because you know my
english skills so it was uh they were
not really that good so
they reflect on everything i mean we you
know whatever you do you know you get to
communicate you have to communicate fast
and very effectively
and i just was lacking that english
skills at the time
the funny thing is that finally i made
it to this platoon so i was not anymore
[ __ ] new guy i was not anymore this
is meat
and we i remember so
when you come back from press platoon or
get back from the platoon from
deployment
you're like hey i got this school i'm
going to sniper school i'm going to this
school i'm going to this school
so i said hey dragon so what school did
you get you know just where are you
going it's like ah dude i'm going to
english 101 i think the next door up
there this is [ __ ]
the regular navy thing and so i spent
the next
three months doing actually english
classes that was not bad
because actually it helped me in my
career in the future so basically
so they legit sent you to english school
yes yes
and uh but that saved my career you know
these guys were
apparently they seen something in me
they say well you know
he bought your english language but he's
were you having a hard time
like communicating like in that going
through the house and stuff yeah
yeah trying to communicate with the rest
of you guys yeah especially the
communication going through the house
and
trying to communicate yeah so at that
time i was still had to i still had to
try
i didn't tell them that but i had to
translate from what i hear to my
polish tank then i have to think of the
solution translate
back to english and say it so i
i i manage that
but it is so much easier later on when
actually i get my english good so
that just flow you know but they still
have to be very fast because
fast what was your what was your
position in that opportunity were you a
gunner
1600 i was the 60 gunner yeah i was 60
gallon i think for the next three
platoons
it's just um i like that you know i
think that's a big
big stink you easy to load because you
don't have to worry about just jamming
this little
piece shooter magazines just put the
tray in it and say i'm
good to go where was your first
deployment was it europe
uh yeah it was in europe that was at the
time uh actually we deployed to
uh san vito in italy okay and
that was when the uh grady got shut down
likes we were looking at him and
you know this has become brings to my
mind too in seal teams you
do every day you do something that can
kill you
i didn't think about it but it does i
remember flying over the adriatic sea
where we're actually on the lookout for
this for
for uh this pilot uh scotty lantern he
was sitting in the
in the he was a sniper so he's sitting
up there and uh
[ __ ] with his gun and we look at it
and i think it was bill white look at
say the puck
say nothing his whole belt just dropped
off so he was sitting on the ledge of uh
i think it was who's scottie yes so the
ramp is open he's sitting on the run
finding with his gun his whole belt is
gone
so he just like i think it was a i think
it was a bill white he just like
sneak up or he can just grab his ass and
just [ __ ] pull him inside this
guy like what the [ __ ] he's like dude
you almost fell out of that [ __ ]
because you know those clips they were
like easy to come undone
i mean it's not really something i would
say
safe that they will stay close on you
so yeah so so that was the thing and
yeah this
comes to my mind there's always there's
something there's some situation that
you can get killed
and if you look over the statistics i
think from the before the war
i think we were killing like two guys in
training every year as the average i
think it was like
when i when i'm looking out this guy
died this guy was killed
in training that's why i got killed and
trained he was like one or two guys
every year yeah for sure
no there's definitely you're doing stuff
every day whether it's parachuting
diving shooting you're always doing
something
that that can give you a bad day or make
you fall out of a helicopter because
your
belt came off yeah so did you guys
did you ever do any work down in uh in
bosnia
yes we went there was no another platoon
we went to bosnia to yugoslavia we spent
time that was pretty good time she was
like it was just good
there was really not much to do at the
time but just work out and get big
so that was a really good platoon
actually there was that this is where i
met the strongest guy
i think in the teams i i think i can
think of
chris s i i don't know if i can bring
his name
i don't have a permission i didn't ask
him so just to be on the safe side but
he knows who he is
when he went to france france i mean
this guy was lifting like what five
plates
the bench bench press so when we went to
france we just got the
french equipment he just bent that [ __ ]
out of the
hell out of their their pry bars when he
picked it up this bright
pry bar i mean the bar bend and those
weights
are falling off so all these frenchies
guys they stopped working with us they
just like
whenever we rolled into their gym they
just sit down like a bunch of
the weird thirds so that
they uh that was actually funny but yeah
there was big platinum i remember so
there was entire platoon
i think over 220 pounds i think there's
one guy maybe he was not but like all of
us was over 220 pounds
of course chris was way much more and
yeah that's i remember for me i wanted
to say i need to join this 220 pounds so
i'm working so hard
and i'm just like i have a pound below
half a pound below like 219 to 18 and
say
[ __ ] give me that loaf of bread right
there so i would just like
i weigh my cells maybe i hate this few
grams to get this 220 pounds
i just chow down push myself into that
bread myself like
get on the scale 220 and a half it's
like
[ __ ] i'm 220 pounds club
now i wish i could get to the 220 pound
from the other side from the top
so then what was it when when i showed
up at team two
what was was that your fourth platoon
yeah i don't remember that i think so or
your third fourth
platoon maybe i think it was yours yeah
i remember you showed up and it's like
i remember i had to swim with you this
before even with platinum so we just
did dive that that swim and i said well
you're a kind of big guy so i don't
think you'll be swimming that fast so i
think i'm straight with you i'll be all
right
and it's like okay look yeah when you
look at me that's your boy
you you swimming with the boy and i was
like okay
and uh so we get in the water [ __ ]
you drag that boy you drag and drag me
and that boy with you
i just could not keep up i mean that was
like where this [ __ ] guy is taking
the
strength from i mean you shouldn't be
you're so big you shouldn't be swimming
that fast
what were you doing like a recall dive
or something yeah i think it was a
recoil dive yeah there was just like
swimming
from one place to another just a couple
of lakes here and there i think it was a
recoil dive
so i remember you dragged me and the
buoy to the [ __ ] water so bad
that's like i think i would just over
breed that goddamn break and
and so that we get put in the platoon
and um
we had a freaking really good workup out
there
oh yeah that was good workout it was a
really good platoon
good deployment too i mean i really
enjoyed
uh this time we went to spain we we
hijacked the russian tanker too
that's that was you know now
when i look at the bag after my
experience in combat i'm sure you too
it's like it's not really that big deal
yeah yeah but at that time there was
like holy [ __ ] we not only hijacked the
russian tanker
uh vulgar knife it was welcome left we
i remember the funny things too is uh
you remember we were doing shifts later
because
it was a russian tanker so there are
those regular nations and just to
clarify everyone for
for the english translation when when
drogla says we hijacked a russian tanker
we actually didn't hijack a russian
tanker there was a
there was a tank or a russian tanker
that was smuggling
oil out of the gulf and one of the
missions that we had while we were over
there was stop people from smuggling
stuff
out of the gulf most of the time we were
taking down little
little dowels little tiny boats and we
would take those things down we took
down a bunch of them too
but then this was the biggest catch that
we got was this big oil tanker that we
that we totally a russian flag
tanker that we took down we got control
of we turned it over to the
the authorities but um so you know we
didn't hijack it
but we did visit the
visits and searches
the final thing is you remember we did
the shifts later right because maybe it
was not comfortable so let's keep seals
on it so just bobbing on this boat
you're bobbing on this boat and
but i remember so when we took it down
we came back and died then the next
shift came back next day the
the other squad that when they came back
saying dude you just left bunch of
weapons with them there is so much
[ __ ] we took all this the weapons that
you guys left i was like
what the weapons did we leave up there i
mean we searched that boat
what are now to be as when they went up
there they see those little butter
patties
the they just [ __ ] took it away from
these guys so when we went back
these guys are coming and said i spoke
russian
so yeah say hey mr uh please help us
we have no teeth and we can't eat
because these guys stole our forks and
our knives so we can
i cannot chew and and there's
like really maybe two or three teeth
sticking out of the mouth and there's
like that's all they had
so i remember yeah yeah we take care so
we actually bring those
butter knives or butter what do you call
it spatulas
and forks back to them so they can
actually eat yeah i also remember those
guys
they were telling us that we didn't do a
good job clearing or whatever they were
saying because they still cause we we're
like oh yeah they have
they have butter knives and stuff like
that and then they're like don't worry
we secured it
yeah and we were sailing that we were on
a navy ship looking at the ship that we
took down
and i'm looking at i was like yeah you
did a good job and i looked over and
there's like a fire
they were like good job you idiots so
they stole their [ __ ]
butter knives and thoughts about leave
the big axes and i say hey
you guys left this all this weapon here
look at this look at this butter
yeah that that was crazy too because
just by sheer luck our platoon commander
went to the naval academy and studied
russian and so he spoke russian yeah we
had another guy that was like
went to berkeley and and he studied
russian
and then you so in a platoon we had
three russian speakers
yeah we took down a russian vessel yep
that's freaking lucky right there
ah that was awesome i remember just at
the very beginning we passed the bridge
and i remember this captain say hey uh
don't cooperate with americans he's in
russian like don't don't say nothing
don't
operate resist as much as you can mr
fiona he understands it he'll say
oh i see he said dragon take care of it
just grab the guy by the scrub
work your hand open the i also have a
big chimney with the door as you open
the door it's like a little tiny space
so i throw in the russian like you
[ __ ] you should say another word
i'm going to squash you right here and
lock you up for the rest of the journey
you just look at this little tiny space
here oh [ __ ] i better don't [ __ ] with
these guys
okay so no problem we never had a
problem with this guy again
so yeah that was a good time
but i tell you i have to say one more
thing here i remember you remember rob
o'neil he was in my in our platoon my
fairly good body and at that time we're
like best friends
and uh i remember he was a sniper on
this op and he said drago i'm going to
happen nothing to you i'm
i'm i'm i'm looking over you and i
remember as we
moved through the ship as we searched i
said like i know what up is up there
ain't nothing [ __ ] is going to happen to
me i know he'd take down that
anybody who's on our way so it makes me
look very comfortable
yeah that was um we had a bunch of we
had a tight
group that was a good platoon yes and
also you were talking about
being big we were also oh yeah we also
we we tried to get a platoon average of
200 pounds
and we had to make up for some slack
because we had some guys
and we i remember we got to uh
we the first place we went was spain
oh yeah and i was trying to get to 250.
yeah and i could same thing i was like
trying i'm eating i'm lifting i'm
squatting i'm eating
and i was i couldn't get above like two
i don't know
245 or something like that and then
where we stayed in spain was they had an
all-you-can-eat buffet for
all three meals of the day yeah and i
was like
oh i got this and like three days later
i was 250 i weighed in and i was like
yeah
250. and then i went on a four mile run
and i was like
okay i need to lose weight this sucks
yeah
[ __ ] but you remember we were living
like our doors were opening right on the
beach
so yeah just walking the sidewalks like
i'm on the beach right there
that was awesome i mean that that was
awesome deployment i really like that
and uh then the bahrain and uh
there was the the christmas party i mean
the christmas time came the new year
came and
kind of got us tighter and close
together too there was the 2000 year
so that was really really good time
and i have very profound memories of it
it's almost like in
very nostalgic to me right now it's just
uh
so yeah um so we get done with that
platoon i know i got back i i
went to college you carried on
um where did you stay at team two or did
you go to a different team uh no because
i think you remember when we came out we
came out as a
in 2000 uh as a as a platoon from seal
team two
we came back as a seal team four at
least some of us so
they remember the division 2000 that
went by oh that's right
right they made some adjustments to the
way they were structuring the teams yes
and so when we got back you
i was informed you went to team four
okay got it so are there
all these uh uh upheavals and all that
stuff eventually
i ended up in one of the patterns that
were
we deploy to south america
we're in puerto rico and we're like
three months into deployment
when they they call me my chief calls me
and say hey um
drago we uh you'll get back that just
want you to pack your shed you need to
help facilitate the polish chrome
with our guys where were you where were
you when september 11th happened
uh i don't see anything too concealed
two quarters i was actually watching it
as it happens and i remember i was
working out i was in the gym
and i see the airplane hit the tower so
it's like what the [ __ ] idiot some
just flew into the thing
but then i was as as the you know the
news progressed and they said like there
was a
not there was a jet liner it was not the
small airplane it just put my attention
i say that's
that's something there's something wrong
here and then the second plane hit the
tower
i remember and uh i still have a hard
time thinking about it it just brings me
all these memories
and and that i was watching the towers
collapse so it just brings tears to my
eyes i can uh
i can't think about it i just at that
time i just want to go and
kill the savages so so
as you're now now fast forward a little
bit
because you're back on deployment you're
at team four you're in puerto rico
you're probably going completely insane
because you're in puerto rico instead of
being either in afghanistan or iraq
yep and then you get a call yes
and i tell you make jealous everybody in
the platoon so how the [ __ ] drago got
this
you know sales we are aggressive there's
a war we want to be in the war
and yeah so i was like [ __ ] hey
this is just incredible i am i'm so damn
lucky i can possibly achieve i can pack
my [ __ ] right now i can
no no no no just go go pack your shirt
just take it take a stab there's a
orders here blah blah blah so they say
what
will happen is we are like i think the
half of deployment at the time so
you just go for another half another
three months just help settle down the
things settle up the ground
come back and join another platoon and
do your work up and
so i'll say yes i was so excited and i
was african i learned the back that
so so just so everyone understands so
there's a there's a polish special
forces
unit they're called grom what does grom
mean thunder
or is that just the call sign it is a
concept but you know you can translate
grom actually as a tender
it is standard it's standard this is
acronym for uh actually
grouper reacts
i can't say this uh so it does it does
stand for something impossible
something but it also means thunder i
mean standard yes there's someone who's
sealed salem is like an animal
right right animal cereal but it's not
really what it is yeah so
so the grom the polish grom had deployed
to baghdad they were actually co-located
with the seals
that were also in baghdad and they
needed someone
to be liaison between the polish grom
and the the seals that were there and of
course
everybody kind of knows or had run into
or someone knew that there was a
polish guy or a america an american guy
that could speak polish that grew up in
poland
that was in the seal teams they track
you down they give
they they contact through your chain of
command and boom
you get the call how long did it take
from the call to they
you fly over there i think a week
or a couple a few days because you know
i had to pack my stuff i had
i still have to process my orders and
uh yeah i packed my stuff it was a fruit
civilian aircraft
too it was funny because i have all the
guns everything and i'm flying civilian
aircraft to
uh to middle east and eventually um
london in baghdad yeah it was
2003. oh wow the heat was incredible
right
when i unpacked my stuff i just stood up
it's like that
that wind blew i was like [ __ ]
where's that aircraft here i thought i'm
like the jet blast of uh
some you know what month did you arrive
i think it was may
maybe so yeah that was hot it's not even
hot yet
oh yeah it's not even hot yeah i mean
like june it's gonna come oh yeah
and then july and august it's on so but
even
may you're like getting there like oh
why it's so hot here where's the jet
engine
so you so you you show up you get to
camp jenny posey
yes so they they get into genie palsy
and uh pastor robin so you know i'm
getting briefed
and uh there's like okay so this is what
we expect from you this is what needs to
happen
so this is where i raised my first alarm
i say
i'm going to sit in the [ __ ] humvee
and watch [ __ ] happens uh
uh i'm here i'm going with these guys if
they go
so you know for the command
our safety is priority so they're like
you know well
we don't know these guys really we we
know they're good but you know
we don't train with them we didn't train
with them that much so
we we set you loose with these guys i
mean you're taking a
we are taking a chances that you can get
hurt
but i said i had no other way i said i'm
i'm i'm going with these guys i mean i
i won't get any respect even from there
i wouldn't respect myself just sitting
in the house doing nothing
so after a little debates they say okay
you can go with these guys so for me it
was good because i was double dipping i
was going with the chrome guys and then
i'll just switch my gear and just go
back with our guys
if i switch your gear you mean change
your clothes did you wear the grom
uniform no no no no no i wear our
uniform but the change might not like if
we use the magazines yeah yeah reload
and go with our guys sometimes on the
fly on the wheels on the fly because
like
we're at that time was with team five so
the ground hit the target then we moved
to another target just switch the cars
and go with the power guys so
i got some of those missions i think
it's pretty good i think freaking living
the dream
no kidding i mean this is like so that's
why you know like three months came in
when i supposed to return
it's like i hear nothing from my
commands so like [ __ ] i ain't saying
[ __ ] either
so i keep going ever actually they are
saying who wants to stay longer here
because that
we have this change but we could
appreciate any change like you know i
guess
i'm i'm here so yes
i stayed and like four months pass like
nobody says anything
five months like nobody says anything i
was like [ __ ] happy as i can be i say
ain't saying [ __ ] to these guys
and uh so like in the eight months so
this is like 11 months the
deployment almost a year
my nvg is broke and i said like guys i
need some help can you guys
loan me your nvgs they say well yeah we
can
you know as a platoon when we deploy our
little gear is limited and we have
something that can
support the platoon on us but not to
launch some other guys
so you know it went for a while while i
was trying to call my team i said hey
guys uh
so finally i got call my team i said i
need nvgs
in baghdad so this guy is like listen to
it it's like what
i say can you send me nvgs to back that
who is this and so drago
so you want me to send equipment to you
somewhere in baghdad i say the compost
you're composing so
and who who you are say who you who the
drago you are who
i was like i'm just drago you know i'm
still team guy and team guy
it's like dude you don't even speak
english do you want me to send the
suicidal bomb vessel with it too
you know just like basically they
thought i'm just iraqi trying to solicit
[ __ ] gear to send to somewhere to
back that and
so i can't really pace uh like dude
[ __ ] if i can kill you when i
get
when i come back and uh and but anyway
get me master chief online so they
could master chief online say master
chief i just need to get some ndgs i'm
here my brogan
say wait wait wait drago where are you
at i say i'm in baghdad master chief
it's like quiet for a second i was like
uh and
how long you have been there i say i'm
like almost a year on deployment and uh
dude you need to come back here because
uh you know see your team such and such
i don't want to bring the numbers here
is about to deploy and we are next you
need to come back
as there was no way to go around it i
mean i could when i go maybe so much but
at that time yeah i had to come back so
they they sent me i came back to little
creek and uh
the funny story so that then the next
team is coming out so i said hey guys i
can go
at that time you get addicted to that
stuff i mean you just you can't live in
normal society just like
dude i just left there i i don't like
this place here
so to to live like this i want to be
there
and uh so i said well i go with you guys
yeah we can use you
know just help us settle down with this
you already been there for so long time
and
you're with chrome so we'll help us you
will help us settle down with
that stuff with grom and so i want that
so jeff will take you for a couple weeks
and uh
for me as like yeah that's awesome it's
a couple weeks of it
as much as i can get so we flew up there
and it's like four months later
it's like hey drago you need to come
back dude we are deploying two months
or something like this and then you need
to be back in to join your platoon
so i say oh [ __ ] okay so i'm as master
chief i'm on the way
so i came back and turned around and
came back again with uh uh
with the with the with with my seal team
four the funny thing is that
on my on my the on this last story when
i was there
the the army guy comes up to me like i
don't know him from adam i was like
i'd never register even the guy he can
say hey dude
have you been here in 2003 i said yeah
i've been here in 2004 yeah
when did did you ever go home even
well for a little time but dude actually
i remember seeing you for for three
[ __ ] years
and i said well if you see me that like
you have been here quite some time too
you know
these guys are doing awesome jobs so the
army guys you know
yeah with them but
yeah and uh that was uh that was my
my iraq time uh um yeah it was
interesting like
when we were there together and just to
give everyone an idea of what was going
on so
the grom there there would be uh
intelligence from various sources coming
down and
we would kind of go out and capture kill
bad guys and sometimes sometimes just we
were basically rotating back and forth
between
grom and the seal platoon grom seal
platoon
and sometimes it would be two targets
and we just go out together and or if it
was a really big target we'd go out
together and maybe grom would be
external security and the seals would do
the assault or maybe seals would be
external security and grom would do the
assault
and i i don't remember you're gonna have
to correct me
but i don't remember
many of them speaking english not many
of the time now everybody everyone
speaks and speaks
speaks very well but at that time yeah
there was only
me and uh who were this is why i was
for me it was great because i was going
on the missions with them i was doing
assaults and the
uh in the storm the the hideouts with
them and with our guys so
i love the thing but yeah they they did
not speak english at the time
yeah so so what i remember is like we
would give our brief and you would stand
there and translate the brief
for them and then they would explain
what they were doing on their target and
you would explain what they were doing
to us
and then anytime that we were you know
if we were if we were kind of doing
something together you
you were really critical for making
the the connection between what the two
elements were doing
this is freaking a pretty big job you
know what there was
it was i think it was important at the
time but eventually
we matched so well that i remember
sometimes was kevin hey guy
hey drago is that guy is the grom guy he
was our guy
so i could say that's our guy you know
it's hard to tell who is who because
we're working so well together
um yeah but you know talking about this
english thing
uh translation and stuff i am
also i think besides being
preacher and breaching in iraq known for
my
english skills actually for my uh
actually i'm going to patent it i'm
thinking about patenting it uh
i became known for being the fastest
english language
uh instructor teacher to terrorists
actually because i developed that course
i call it
drago's accelerated english language
course for terrorists
basically you give me five minutes with
the terrorists because they always say
remember
i don't speak no english no english
mistake no english mistake
i i teach you five minutes later the guy
actually could speak with better accent
that i could ever say things so that's
that's i think that i'm very proud of my
skills and uh so that's
that that that i'm thinking about
patenting it eventually because that's
you know it's it worked so well yeah
uh it was it was awesome too like when i
when i said that the
translating between us and the grom
you're right like we'd be out on the
target
and we wouldn't there would be very
little that you would have to translate
because
we all knew what the mission is knew
what we were doing we would
interact very well together and just
like just like seals i mean when you're
out in a seal
operation you're not talking about
you're but you're basically especially
on those types of missions you're barely
saying anything
so it was it was not like you were all
the time having to translate
but there was a couple times or or there
would be times where it's like oh
we need to know what they're doing what
are they doing right hey dragon where
are they going right now
it's like oh they saw a guy they saw a
squirter they're going to get them like
cool roger that
yep just just taking care and and
bringing those two units together
man it was an awesome working
relationship that we had with the grom
it was freaking awesome they were
great guys i really enjoyed that work
because
especially there you know we have all
the same
roes but the interpretation of this
arrow is well but maybe a little bit
more
loose or not so strict so they were
strict they were
they apply everything that needs to be
applied to roes but they were also
realistic
about that stuff so uh it was pleasure
to work with them
uh the funny things was that if i mix it
up you know i had that switch where i
had the earphones the peltors with one
connected the polish chrome one to us so
if i switch the wrong strong way and
it's like drago
god damn speaking english [ __ ]
or there's a switch the other one
dragged we don't understand [ __ ] you
just say speak polish
i have to be very careful you know you
you you can do things very fast in
combat
and then you have to just switch this
thing the right way because which is the
wrong way it's like
yeah if we don't understand you what we
don't speak polish drago
so you're there for o3 you got there in
may you're there oh four you're there my
whole deployment which was
from uh 03 like
october 203 or something like that fall
of o3 to
some to spring of oh foreign and then
you
you went back for a little bit did you
go back i went back with my platoon then
i came back to seal team four and
we are just in for us deploying and
backing again
back again for another six months so
that was pretty cool
uh the thing is you know what what it
does
to uh is
i remember it becomes almost
unreal this world here i remember
uh i was talking to my girlfriend at the
time
and say hey um i need to go and to go
home i'm tired now so it's
like that's so stupid you're not your
home is not there your home is here and
blah blah blah
oh [ __ ] okay well whatever you know but
the the reality is
that uh that place becomes your home
when you think about this this world
about people walking on the streets
making groceries
it become a dream almost like a state
that's just like yeah it is there you
know but
like now you hear the fa when you think
about the fairy tales
some you know snow white or something it
sounds really great but but it's just
like a
fairy tale so for me this war became
a fairy tale it was just like a you know
it's there it's awesome but i'm here and
this is my reality and that was almost
like a dream you know sometimes it was
like i was dreaming
being in normal world and and uh
yeah so that's that become that world
here become very distant to me become
almost unreal because their my reality
was
the war and i liked it i mean that was
at that time i thought i liked it but
i have to tell you because you know my
job i was i'm preacher
so i remember after at the end of
deployment
the first deployment i started having a
problems reading i couldn't read
so i remember trying to read the
sentence and my eyes were jumping so i
had to read it over and over and
then when i finished reading it i don't
remember what i started sentence with
so it took me sometimes five six minutes
to get through a paragraph
and i think this is because of the
conclusion i mean
we are exposed to these uh to this stuff
and i did it was a couple times that i
you know like we we suppose we are going
explosive bridge through the door
that we look at the intel pictures and
there was like okay okay so this is how
we plan you know we we
prepare all the the briefs this is where
we hide
this is where the assault element is
going to be there's the breachers we're
going to go blow the door
this is how we go well some of those
pictures were not very accurate and i
remember around the situation that
we had uh i had the the assaulting stash
there i went
sent the recharge with the guy came back
and
i had no place to hide i was like [ __ ]
this and you remember most of these
uh uh most of these uh
buildings or these uh hideouts were fans
of their defenses and stuff so
once we climb inside there's really no
place to hide and i had to blow my that
ship pretty much on myself it's like a
[ __ ] hey
i can't i'm not going to make your rook
is running for looking for some
place to hide so i just took a knee put
the gun in front of my face and [ __ ]
blow this [ __ ] out
it i remember i didn't remember much
after that i mean i got
my force for my for my legs and i
was bleeding from my nose and here then
but what's what kind of like always
puzzled me is like what the
[ __ ] is my side i mean i have like the
bruce like [ __ ] broke my
ribs where that [ __ ] came from so the
ground is like the dude you are on your
phones who just have to kick you out of
the way because
there's no way to ride you know you were
just you you were just there
on your force and uh we so basically
kicked me out of the way the key was so
strong that
almost broke my ribs but you know this
is normal it's not that's something that
you accept because
that's yeah yeah as as a breacher
man but those are those operations like
those breaches that you guys were doing
and i would usually position myself
where i would be kind of would there be
a wall i would sort of put myself
on top of the wall on top of the ladder
so i could see the breach i could see
the building i could see if there's any
enemy movement
and then right as you guys would say
turning steel
i would duck down
i'm actually ducking down behind the
wall because there there could be frag
and stuff like that
oh yeah absolutely but but you guys were
inside
those compound walls and you're probably
whatever eight feet 10 feet 12 feet away
from the blast
and so i like i said i get a little
little bit of protection
and i don't feel as much concussion the
concussion is going up and then as soon
as the breach goes i
jump over the wall and go we go do our
thing but
you know you guys are just taking that
breach on a nightly basis taking that
hammer to the brain and look i know
there's some of them
where you know it would be really bad
and it might knock you out
but even the ones that don't knock you
out even the ones that you just
oh you just you just suck up that thing
and it doesn't knock you out and then
you go
yep that thing is not good for you like
those breaches are not good for you
and who knows how many hundred
hundreds of times you just took that
took that concu took that minor
concussion and over time
it's definitely gonna it's gonna
freaking leave a mark accumulates yes
but as you know we're not aware
so acutely of the issue then as we
know now what it does to you and you you
you right you learn
you you know you get
shaked
sometimes of the ground just your feet
go up there right sort of the blast
but then you just go in you move on you
you are old onto
autopilot basically you know what to do
you train for years to do it
so this is what i like that i'm saying i
was so effective i i enjoyed that skills
i could apply
as an nvc also that's uh that was uh
that was great feeling but yeah it does
and we're not that great feeling you
know when you get knocked out or bleed
from your ears and knows but
uh but they're just the the the the
the tactics and techniques like how
effective they are and how well they
work
yeah when you said good feeling i was
just thinking about like when i got to
baghdad so you'd already been there for
a long
for i don't know eight months
but i remember just being so freaking
happy to see you and i was like
because we already did a platoon
together we already had awesome times
together
yeah and i just was like that's so
freaking stupid that's another thing to
going with your platoon
i i i think this is for some reason i
talked to other guys
we feel [ __ ] safe it's like dude [ __ ]
is not going to happen to us nothing is
going to happen to us
i think i think because that that the
way
your platoon was fired up the way you
were fired up the way it was
uh i mean i think the leadership has a
lot to do with it how you feel about
this
that they've given up and for us it was
just like
[ __ ] i can operate like this forever
all right so let's talk about when you
when you get back home after you spend
all these months and months over there
and you were talking about how the the
concussion
like you're you're trying to read and
you see
the the freaking words are moving around
and
you get done with a sentence you can't
remember what did you when when that
when that first started happening to you
what were you thinking
i was thinking keep it quiet because
they will move me out of the platoons
they won't let me go to war so i just
keep my mouth shut and say nothing
so did you go back into another platoon
at this point yeah there was there was
after the first
the first deployment uh sorry so i did
two more uh
combat tours with that uh but uh coming
back
talking about the returning uh from this
there was like almost a year
being deployed i remember i landed in
norfolk and the guy said like okay hey
go ahead and uh you want me to help you
something
i had all my gear and all the stuff from
puerto rico yet because i just came back
from
i went to from basically from puerto
rico to iraq
so i had to get my old gear so i stuck
my gear on the curb
it was uh it was called and i was so
tired i remember uh
again i said in other words these guys
are coming to pick me up so i'm good
so he left shut the door and there was
like nobody there you know the norfolk
military airport and i [ __ ] fell
asleep just like [ __ ]
getting dark i'm freezing my ass off i
say what the [ __ ] i don't know for a
second
where am i saying i'm not for what
[ __ ] didn't show up
so like my phone is dead so i was like
[ __ ] i can't even call them it's getting
[ __ ] night and cold there's nobody
there
so i was like hey it's trying to knock
on the door hey hey
can i need the phone so uh
nobody shows up i was like i'm so
[ __ ] cold the time i'm just
saying i need to get inside because i'll
get hypothermia i grabbed this [ __ ]
big concrete garbage thing i was about
to swing it into the window
and this guy was like she opens the door
i say dude i need to make a cow
these guys didn't show up so so
i kind of my phone is dead i can i don't
even have a phone
i don't remember because my brain is
already so messed up don't remember uh
the number
two group it's kind of the team there's
a weekend so that
team is not there uh can call the group
that's so they say hey uh and somebody's
supposed to pick me up today a few hours
ago and
i'm still in the parking lot and you are
who i say i'm drago
where are you coming from i think from
back that i said [ __ ] up
we don't have anybody in baghdad yet we
are not even there you [ __ ] need it
and just [ __ ] hang up they thought
they were just i don't know what they
think
i said that so um you know group two
there's no
not necessarily seals on the quarter
like there's like anybody who are the
logistic people
so i call back again and say hey
[ __ ] give me od the officer of
the deck
i need officer nick because i need to i
just came back from back that i need to
get back to the teams
so you say they call od and say hey this
is drago i just came here
for a few hours ago it's a guy supposed
to pick me up she don't have to pick
anybody up today he just look
oh hey drago we are so sorry i'll just
send the track right now so
we're on that we are on the way so yeah
they sent the guy
the tech came in and um great guy i
really liked him
uh so he he came in they load my gear we
got team four
they took my guns away so they they put
it away they
uh all my gear are just unloaded in my
cage
and i just have something just take me
uh
something into my mind like [ __ ] i
haven't by this time the girl from the
life to me she just said like
you you are done she called me on
christmas say that she needs to move on
and i'm
she don't have time for this [ __ ] so uh
so i'm like she had my car and my stuff
but i had so i have no car the car is
parked somewhere in her place
my my clothes are there everything i had
was
like cruise box world of things but was
in her place
so i said i just get can i take this key
and stole the key from the
one of those pickup trucks outside from
that store i just like borrowed it
and i'm glad i did because uh the guy
work out we work outside he shuts the
door and i say hey
what's the code i need to get inside he
said you guys are still sleeping in the
[ __ ] teams in the cages you can't do
that anymore there's new regulations you
are not allowed to go
sleep in the teams i said i have no
place to go
he said well tough [ __ ] man um he lived
he just dropped the kind of life i was
like what the [ __ ]
so i tried to remember that the code uh
i don't remember i can't i can't
remember it
so we have those little punching things
because they stopped the quarter like
do this some time ago and uh so i can
remember that i said like [ __ ] but i am
so hungry now i just need to do
something i just need to
grab something to eat so i i
had no money but i put my credit card
not credit card by the
then have a credit card but my atm card
it's like maybe
15 dollars so uh that's like [ __ ] i just
need something i
cut ten dollars out of it so what can i
just say
i hope so i drove to
in virginia beach to ihop that's why the
i think there was there at that time
borders bookstore
and i came up to this thing and i
started
got me those uh cheese blends i love
cheese blends so that's from the from
the i hope so
got me cheese plans got me a coffee i
signed out and took a fight and i got so
sleepy so tired i just [ __ ] fall
asleep up there
and then next thing is the guy the
security officer comes out
hey what are you doing here
i mean you are sleeping here i'm
watching you in here for like
five hours or so and this is like i
think two o'clock in the morning
uh hey i mean
what's the problem i said like i'm
looking at him i'm still trying to
get that uh my wits together he looks at
me it's like yeah the [ __ ] kicked you
out then she i was like
yeah the [ __ ] kicked me out yeah yeah
so i said do you mind if i just go relax
tomorrow morning and
today morning i'll just go and uh
you know i just buy some more food if i
need to say no no
you're fine just go relax and you know
just don't cause any problems i'm sorry
no no problem so in the morning i woke
up and slept in the
i hope so i woke up and uh went to group
two get some phone calls and
most of the guys were i think team four
at that time they were doing something
because they were
deployed we were ready to deploy it
again so uh
once i get hold of somebody and then i
get the code
back to the team and then i was like
this is not only me as abandoned that
team gets this bunch of
there's always some team guys sleeping
in the cage because it's kicked out from
the house his girlfriend kicks him out
or
has this problem or his there's no place
to leave for sure so so you know it's
like
i moved into the in the cage and uh that
was pretty cool because the platoon had
you have all the cable tvs you have a
shower you have a gym
24 hours seven and uh so it was only me
but it's like a bunch of guys hey drago
you should just bang on the door
somebody would come out and just open
the doors for you
i didn't know anybody was here we were
told that we cannot there's nobody
in the teams anymore that thing is gone
nah [ __ ] this just playing cards and
doing all kinds of cook they're schools
that's really cool
and then you know we're just we deploy
again but then
i deploy again but that was the first uh
my first comeback was not only that but
then i find out that
my checks are bouncing i look at the
bank and they save no money at all i say
what the [ __ ]
so i go to them and they say drago you
didn't fill your travel claims
so travel claims i was in iraq without
wounded
i was not moving anywhere i was there
for like eight months nine months and
then
you we were told not to worry about the
travel claims
well we just garnish your money so you
aren't getting any paycheck you're just
getting maybe like three
whatever that proportion was that they
allowed to leave
so i said dude i'm so [ __ ] sick and
pissed
about that and uh i'm i tell you this
i'm just going to make me a sign
uh iraqi veteran i work for food and
i'll go in front of that [ __ ] gate up
there and start get some money because i
need to eat
so i said no no i didn't need to go that
far you know it's just
we loaned you the money and actually the
chief mess you actually
loan me the money so i can buy some food
and pay some bills
of course i paid it back but i was so
mad i called this uh
that those civilians they worked the
travel claims in group two and just
relayed it to them and they show up i
yield them
let's see so next thing the chiefs calls
me hey drago
you're not allowed to group two you have
they call provosts and i think we have a
problem so
we just told them that if you show up in
group two you'll be always chief
assisting you and you go with chief up
there so because you really scared these
people out there
i was like okay chief that's no problem
and um
and you know just work my way work my
way out of this pay my some pay
those travel claims you know fill the
travel claims they did return some of
the money
and um it was all good you know that's
uh
um that's then i deploy again and again
and uh the this with the eyes first i
was
i was coming with all kinds of theories
like maybe my eyes are bad maybe the
tent is dark
so i use the flashlight i use this and i
can't [ __ ] read
so i just i just give up i say maybe i'm
just not smart enough
and i just like move on i was busy with
other stuff so
it came back later that how many more
deployments did you do
uh three two two more to iraq so
what year was your last one 2005 2003
2004 and 2005.
and then what'd you do when you got home
from from that deployment from that
deployment
uh you know at that time i also you know
before you even jump into that i
i s like there's a certain transition
period and there's a there's like a
you know when you're overseas and
especially for you
you have one basically one purpose in
life when you're over there
like you get it you get your mission
tasking you you figure out what the what
the plan is
you get your gear together you brief the
guys you go out you do your hit you come
back
it's the simplest life
yeah it's like a customer service the
government customer service
i would look at it but my customers were
always bad and i got to kill them
and then you but you come home and all
of a sudden there's all these other
things
right there's the freaking travel claims
and there's like apartments and there's
all these other things that you gotta
try and
like deal with again and and
sometimes just that is you're just not
it takes a little bit of time to get
used to
what you were saying you were saying
that the normal world
doesn't really exist anymore and then
when you come back and you get injected
back into it
sometimes it takes a little time to get
used to
okay there's this this is what this is
what i've got to deal with i got to go
stand in line at the
dmv like a normal freaking human being
which i have
you know let's face it if you
if there was someone in the way when
you're you know it's like when we were
when we were doing
operations when we were driving if there
was a vehicle in the way you freaking
just
knocked the vehicle off the road like
you got plowed out of the way and then
you drive on
if there's a person that's in the way as
you're moving towards a target you just
freaking clear them out of the way it's
just no factor
yes and so you you get in that mindset
of
okay i'm going to make happen whatever i
need to make happen to get the mission
done that's the mindset that you get in
and you get back and and you realize
okay it takes a little time to realize
that you can't
just go you can't stay in that mode
because
that mode is not that mode is actually
considered to be criminal
and destructive and destructive in
america in the normal
civilian populace yeah i remember but my
first feeling was even when i was
sleeping in the ihop when i came back
it's kind of relief too when i
i'm just looking around i see these
people eating or
walking around saying that's that's
that's the normal life but i was
i forgot about it almost because it was
so immersed
into that combat into that um
the time there that again this became
like a dream then you come back it's
like
oh that's actually real you know that's
uh but also big relief
i never realized that that that thing
over your head always well i can get
shot
we don't think about it it never
bothered me but then when i came back i
was like
i'm going to get shot so it's like well
first thing is i'm
i'm good i'm okay now but then come the
reflection you think about the guys that
did not come back
and that's it still bothers me and um
that's uh uh i think they will always
stay with with us
uh forever that uh almost i don't know
it's
called like the the survival survival
guilt
that uh that's what they call it why me
why him not me
and um
this is why i'm trying to cherish the
memories of the guys that i knew they
are not here anymore
because you know it fades and
i think they are alive in
they still live in our minds
so what we can do for them is just
remember them because if we forget
who we remember so they they're still
alive they are alive in our
minds we see them we remember them and
we need to cherish this
so it is so important to
write the books about these guys who are
not here anymore because who write they
can write their own book
we need to engage parents and that was
just our parents of our guys look
um they might not seem like a lot but
you wake up and you know this the pain
doesn't go away just live to land with
it
as a parent as a spouse but what you can
do is just write
little things that you remember uh you
just you wake up it's like
yeah i remember he was doing this and
that when he was a little kid
write this down because those memories
are fleeting you might not remember it
10 years down the road
but eventually if you keep doing this
you will write the full picture the
image
of your child of your spouse who is no
longer with us but
it helps all of us remember it so it is
important that you do that and uh
hopefully people are doing it because
you know that eventually become a book
and maybe you want to share
the parent or the spouse want to share
with us the other person that we don't
know
because most of us know the guy the guy
like [ __ ] warrior you know he goes up
there he kills the bad guys he does what
needs to be done
but there's also another side to each of
us and
we don't know that side of these people
who didn't come back
so it is important that we help maintain
that
memory of these guys
yeah there's um no doubt about that and
even
you know with with the opportunity i
have here um
talking to guys talking to veterans from
other wars as well
and just just hearing their stories and
they still carry on the memories
guys that guys from the korean war guys
from vietnam
that what you're saying is absolutely
true and
there's like i read a lot of books that
guys have written and that's
that's the memory that's what they left
behind and they they remember
and they account for the friends and
brothers that they lost in combat and
it's
it's priceless it's priceless for us
this is how we keep them alive you know
that's how we keep their memories
by keeping their memory alive because
they live in our minds
so so you end up doing
another did your next two deployments
were those back to iraq again
yeah yeah and then when i came back i
realized that you know i'm 45 i haven't
at that time
my girlfriend dumped me because my
career was not really good i wasn't
making enough money
actually she actually said in the email
that uh
that really not that's not the place she
wants to be in
so i say [ __ ] i mean i'm i'm like
hitting 45 i'm getting old guy
and i don't have a don't know even girls
you know i don't know
i don't have anybody so i'm going to go
and
find somebody how do i find somebody i
think the easiest way just go online and
look for somebody so i remember
there was this there's a site american
singles
and uh i said [ __ ] yeah i'm american i'm
going to go and get me a wife
so so american and i'm single this
site's for me
so um so
i can't write very well right so i
remember
so we are going trying to finally i
found the girl i was like
she's so beautiful i'm going to go into
let me see if i can wing to her i just
need to tweak my age a little bit
because she's so young so
she's like maybe she's 13 years younger
so i just tweak my age a little bit
so wink to her just to write something
she's got to look at it and she
she went back she wrote she wrote back
and she wrote so nicely
so i said park if i write to her she
just
she just fired me right from the get
cause she won't even talk to me
so so i took the team guys hey can you
help me write the
letters what let's love letters so
so we're going on we had guys writing
the love letters to my
present wife but uh just helping me out
you know because when i write in the
if i when i write this like is what i
ask you know i be what i be your love
letter was
i like you yeah you like me yeah
yeah me love you very much and
so that wouldn't go well and uh so the
guys
kept doing it and so i'm looking at this
i'm reading her letters
and this is so [ __ ] awesome she
writes so well she's so polished she's
uh
so educated then i find out you know
she's air force academy graduate
uh so i was like oh damn this like make
it
uh how many how many years did you chop
off your age
when you initiated this relationship i
think five
because uh and i'm glad i did because uh
we're not talking here later so she had
like a kind of limit if somebody
contacted her about that limit yeah
uh she's just like it's a disappear so
you were 45
she was how was she 57 she was
37 36 36 so you you
brought yourself down to a clean 40. yes
uh like maybe 39 40.
so i was strong i was i was still
i still look young and also like she can
tell but when she sees me she will like
me so
um so i i
uh so the guys keep writing me but
eventually
i say look drago we wrote you like i
think hundreds of these letters
so i think you can what you can do right
now is kind of
paste and post you can just make any
letter you want just that's you know
that copy and paste
so i'm like [ __ ] a bit worried about
it but say
okay yeah i have like every letter so
she wrote
me an email um and uh i tried to like
make some
things out and i guess it didn't go well
because uh
i sent a letter and says click she
disappeared from that
what i found out later is that uh she
read that letter
and the she's her friends and her came
to conclusion that i'm either on drugs
or drunk
so that they work very well so he'll be
better safe than sorry
so she left i was like [ __ ] i think i
[ __ ] up so that like that guy's
looking say yeah drago you did [ __ ] that
you just put the [ __ ]
backwards so i like damn okay i need to
start over again and then she shows up
again
well she shows up because i find out
later that they offer her 30
30 more free days like a freebie so
somebody else
so she said i'm sure okay they said
we're sorry about that last draco guy
we apologize here's your money back and
you get 30 more days to find a normal
human being yeah okay
yeah i guess you know something
everyone but she shows up i was pretty
desperate at the time i really liked her
i really
i loved him you know we talked for a
while we wrote a lot of letters i mean
my team guys wrote a lot of letters and
she was lucky to me
so um so then uh
uh and she didn't respond so i was like
was spending just just colony
just just counting wait did you never
had you talked before
no just she was she's very proper she
was like i'm not going to talk to you i
don't know you even i don't want to give
you my phone number or anything
but eventually acquires her into calling
me had you told her your life story had
you told her
that you had come from poland or were
you telling her that you were a
freaking uh hedge fund manager in new
york or something
no no i just told them i'm in the navy
i'm doing well
and you know just just try to just be
very
very uh vague about it i think that's
maybe she didn't like it either but
i'm just trying not to talk because if i
say yeah i'm sorry i just came back from
iraq so that my guy might be crazy or
something
so i tried to stay out of it but anyway
the guys did a really good job you know
they
if they stay with me they could continue
i think i would have no problems
whatsoever but
anyway i created a letter it came out as
a druggie or some drunk person and then
she's just like
i don't mess with that so um
finally finally got her to call me and i
say look this is me this blah blah so
i i told her about myself and she's like
quiet for a second say
oh you just don't speak english very
well it's not you are drunk and drugs
right it's like
oh yeah yeah i don't do any drugs you
know i don't drink
only on occasions and maybe wine
sometimes
so we started talking about and then
finally she agreed to come and visit me
i was totally in love and
uh yep we are married now
but yeah that was that was a big thing
that uh that
uh yeah she thought that maybe i'm not
not quite right in my head i was not
but yeah we are married we have two
children now and uh together
uh a little girl 12 years old and the
10 years 11 years old boy so how did you
wrap up your your navy career
when i met her i went to master chief
and i was still instructor at the time i
was in buzz
i said look i don't have any family i
have this girl right here
if i go to toward
a deploy i'm i'm just really scared to
lose her
i've been there so many times so long
time maybe
you can find me some post that i can uh
just
get married i just wanted to get married
since i want to secure this girl
and uh so
first they say okay we'll try to help
you drago but the letter from command
came in well for that position who is
somebody who is really polished
and who speaks english very well and
drago is neither one
i i seen this email that was shown to me
so i say [ __ ] i'm wearing this girl
anyway
but eventually i was able to win they
called that
they sent me to ohio nrd
and uh we got married of course
and i retired from there and it was kind
of
i'm glad it happened this way because
that transition kind of
brought me back to reality you know this
is not about just killing people and
beating them up
it is more also about the leading
society being productive member of
society
so so that there was a good transition
period
for me that i could actually relax and
join the society back again and uh
not be a villain but be a good person
and uh
and yeah i got domesticated now so i'm
the nice
nice drago and uh and
the life is good my wife she's
she has master's degree in
bioengineering she's about to do
her phd and
i'm here to support her so we're doing
well
and i just miss the teams definitely
well you're always going to miss the
teams and uh by the way you were you
were
you you may have felt like a villain in
some way but i can tell you bro you were
you were never a villain to me you
you're always always freaking there
always there every single time um
on the good guys side so
when you retired what did you do what
did you do once you retired
what year did you retire 2011. okay
so before retirement
uh i was like
i was told i need to do this i need to
do this and to do that
uh you know when you come back from war
i think there's some issues
linger with you and it's like well i
didn't really care about the
doing the tab meetings about that i just
wanted to go retire and
move on with my life i didn't really
want to really know what i'm going to do
but i was good in the programming and
the the software development
and my wife said like what you need to
do is
put your resume here and
start looking for the job so finally i
said
okay okay i don't have the formal
educator i'm a seal
i don't write software i kill people so
um
i need to do something so say no no no
you do have experience you say you did a
lot and
she wrote she helped me write the resume
at the time so i put the resume
and i said my good luck yeah somebody
willing to call me
back then five days later to say hey
we're looking we have a position here
would you like to come and talk to us
so i was like sure absolutely yes so i
ran up up there and i got the job
before i retired i already have a job
like i think in two weeks before
retirement i got the job so
i didn't started yet until my but my on
my leave
i was working so my my retirement lead
and uh and that's rolled in you know
they're just
getting more and more experience i
learned more and more from the guys
from the software engineers working with
me and
so my life is what it is right now i'm
actually
i i end up developing quite a few
programs one of them is connecting
with this is as you know my
views my i'm very open about the
socialism and how dangerous the
socialism is
that uh when any time i posted on
facebook something about socialism they
banned me they would just basically stop
my account
people were calling me names and i
couldn't even respond to it because
facebook was
facebook was blocking it so i say [ __ ]
these guys
[ __ ] communists i'm going to go and
they'll create my own facebook
so i create connecting and we have
thousands of people right now on the
side posting there isn't
no censorship everybody's welcome it's
not that
the the right left side says you know if
you have if you like to say something
and not to be worried about
being banned or ostracized by uh zuken
[ __ ] whatever his name is and or this
other twerp from twitter
come to connexing and you are welcome to
to say whatever you like to say you know
just please keep the violence down and
uh
not nothing violent but just you're
welcome to speak
be open so so it's it's connect
zing z-i-n-g connect zing and
what i'm i'm now a member of connect
zing i'm on there
one thing that i i was thinking about as
you were telling her talking about
everything today
i mean it couldn't there couldn't be any
better
parallel between what you experienced in
life
and and starting this so at one point in
your life
the communist government
shut down all communications inside of
your country
and completely suppressed the populace
and what you did back then
as a freaking whatever 19 18 20 year old
was you said okay they're trying to stop
us from communicating
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
start a freaking newspaper
and we're to go and we're going to run
around in the background we're going to
print it and we're going to distribute
it out there to people
so even as a kid you realize
the importance of free speech
pretty speech yes and so now you're in a
situation where
you you got banned from the the the
social media platforms
and so you did you're doing the same
thing okay look you don't want me to you
don't want me to
speak you don't want me to have free
speech okay here i go
and so you created this website and this
platform
that people can now communicate and they
don't have to have
any fear of being
being suppressed yes and it is important
for me
i i see that i think we are going the
wrong direction
that suppression of free voice
eventually will destroy can destroy our
country
um the socialism has seven things in
common whether this is adolf hitler
socialism
adult hitler national socialism whether
it's bernie sanders socialism or policy
socialism
they all have one thing in common is
intimidation violence
poverty having a villain
like stalin joseph stalin had the kulaks
those wealthy passions they were
villains they were always vilified
adolf hitler had jewish people he
vilified this
entire group and pelosi have act seems
to me like veterans and middle class
so that's so the the villain is very
important
element of socialism but also political
prisoners
and political murders and the biggest
hallmark of i think totalitarian social
estate is
where state entities are attacking and
intimidating political opponents
we had irs uh you remember i'm sure
remember that
attacking and vilifying the opponents
and other state entities so this is
where i think we are in a very dangerous
spot
and we need to act on it political
prisoners you know then socialism they
always say we don't have
political prisoners because nobody sees
for political reasons
he sees for stealing a milk this guy
states for just maybe driving on the
curb
with his car this guy sits for something
else but there's no political prisoners
but they all sit for political reasons
and you know we have here general flynn
i mean what happened to him you always
find something
that you can show me a man i'll i'll
stick the paragraph to him so they will
find something
to intimidate political opponents and i
think it's time to turn around our
country we can have
the things that are happening right now
are very disturbing to me
they're too much like that socialism
that i experience and i just like i said
earlier
if people only took time to ask
refugees from the former socialist
countries
in eastern europe and stood against evil
you wouldn't have any democrats left
in the office i tell you that it is so
it is so bad i mean um i'm really
concerned
yeah we had some uh we had some
vietnamese
vietnam war veterans on and they
certainly expressed
very similar concerns they lived through
communism they escaped
communist countries and they hate seeing
and they're they're they're sickened
when they see similar uh similar things
occurring here and they you know it's a
warning
it's a warning it is a warning you
better hate it before it's too late
if not too late already because
yeah that's uh we we already have we're
ahead socialist elections and seems like
the rules are being implemented
i was when i was talking to people about
in 2008
that was laughed off it's like that's
not going to happen here
we have we have been we are having now
right now
implement the rules are being
implemented
allowing for socialist elections
socialist elections i mean
elections where communists marxists and
socialists always win
now on top of that and i know
that you got that going on you also have
you also have a foundation
to help guys that we're in the seal
teams guys that are in the seal teams
if they if they run into hard times for
whatever reason you have a
a fund that people can donate to what's
what's that all about
as this navy seals fan there's 501 c3
navysealsfun.org not foundation is navy
seals fund
fund and this is to help our guys
because
there's a lot of team guys that
leave the teams before their time before
the retirement
and they have pretty much no have no
support or very little support
um so and i've seen
so many guys going with broken lies
because
they missed the payment here they missed
the payment there the the the
the the work they'd lost the job
some of them the the whole life was
collapsing in front of them
so what we create is like no red tape uh
uh
charity that look if you were anytime at
any time
53-26 we will help you
we don't let you fall down and uh it's
uh
just no nobody
gets paid so if you can look at our
website there's a bunch of team
guys with the same attitude with the
same
ideals that we we need to help each
other
and again they don't want to get paid
they don't want the money it is not
about the money this is something that
we can give
back to those less fortunate because
there's a big problem look i was lucky i
i came back i met my wife she was able
to domesticate me
and and and create a human being out of
me again but there's a lot of guys that
come back or
or do they they get caught up
in this uh uh in this violent cycle
that you know the skills
from the navy seal teams don't translate
well on civilian
uh in civilian life not many things or
many
some people have a hard time in the
transition so what is happening with
these guys is
well you know what i'm i can't get the
job but what i'm going to do i'm going
to go
get contracting i'm going to go overseas
again you know should
shoot some you know do pretty much the
same job
but when i come back with a lot of money
i can get the regular job i can
get with my bag with my family the guy
comes back after six months with tons of
money he's trying to find the job six
months later he has no job
and he has no money what do you do well
i'm tired
they're tired they just
have no choice i say i need to get back
i need to go back into that
world again so and that cycle repeats
itself we have a guys caught up in this
cycle you know not everybody there are
some people that like this lifestyle and
they can continue on but there's many
guys that can't get out of it
so this is where we step in we want to
go and help these guys
if you want to get out of this uh we are
here to help you and uh
we we stay watch over you
awesome awesome man look we've been
going for a while now
uh probably a good place to um
probably good place to wrap up i know uh
you know you know what we missed you
know we didn't talk about was one of my
funnest things in life
was was introducing you to jiu jitsu
oh that was a great thing and how
excited you were
you were so excited when you learned
that you could choke
people and you could arm lock people and
i remember you got to a scrap somewhere
we were you know out somewhere and you
got into a scrap
and and you i wasn't there you came back
to me the next day and you
you you had the you had a look of just
joy on your face
and you said choco choco and i was like
what's going on man you said i got in a
fight last night and i was like
okay did you get in trouble he's like no
no no no i choked the guy
i choked him you were so happy and so
proud and i and i was quite proud as
well
actually i have to do an ought to do
something too because this is what they
sometimes get old and misunderstand even
within
our community within our guys so you
know when i used to fight when i was
the way i grew up is you you fight until
you destroy the guy
that the fight is over not when the guy
tells you okay well
i got it you know that is over you know
you are better
and then as soon as you turn around he
launched he launched edu so you just
beat the guy until he doesn't move
and then which is what you need to be
careful with is it actually happened to
me before
that he'll then choke on his own tongue
if you roll the wrong way
now you need to go because the police
about to come in so just if you're
living there
like he dies or not so the technique
that
i learned in poland is a pinup type so
you just pin up they make a pin up out
of the guy you you you put the pen
through his lip into his tongue and pin
his tongue to his lap
so that way whatever he rolls in was
once you leave he's not going to
suffocate on his own tongue
and people are like oh so so what what's
what
is it real yeah it is real because the
then you can leave and safely guy
in the in in that position and when he
wakes up he just
feel that he has a safety pin in edges
and pin his tongue from his lab and go
home
versus being dead you know and then you
get in trouble so
so yeah that's that's actually good
technique that uh
a lot of people are thinking i think
adopted i think because i told that
quite a few guys there was also a good
one where
we were going through some kind of
combatives training
and the instructors they had like these
boxes
like taped on the floor and the purpose
of these boxes was that
if you had to handle a situation you
know
in a hand-to-hand situation those boxes
represented the
area that you needed to stay in because
if you got out of that area you're
actually interfering with other guys
field of fire so it was almost a way for
them to prove that look
you just need to stay still and whatever
if you can't do it inside of this little
box here
then it's probably not going to work and
so they
they did some things with me with with
grappling and it was kind of funny but
then they take you
and they go all right you know you stand
in this box and they put
another like one of the instructors in
the box
and they said you know if you're in this
little space like this you know these
kick these kicks that you're talking
about they wouldn't work because you're
you're too close
yeah they were demonstrated yeah and
then so then they go up they go uh
okay drago you know you're standing in
this box you're not allowed to leave the
box
but try and kick him try and kick him in
the head
and uh i did apparently they didn't know
that you had
very flexible legs and why you freaking
kicked this guy in the head
we loved his books he was definitely out
of the box
it was freaking awesome um but you know
i remember too i'm so glad
that you mentioned about this because
when you show up in the platoon
i remember just came and i said guys i'm
going to check out the entire platoon in
five minutes
okay so you started it and as the
progress
like within a 30 seconds you people are
tapping out or pass out
next next so i've seen like a couple
guys quietly just inching their way out
of the
so you know you check out whoever was
left up there including myself but uh
that was actually good experience and uh
we there we started learning
and i remember i remember that i was not
that technically i was pretty strong but
not technically very well
and i was wrestling with one of the
officers and i remember i was trying
almost
everything i was pin i had to pin him
down i was but i almost ripped his hand
off and didn't work and didn't work he
was laying there
and i was trying everything i find like
30 minutes later he finally tapped out
and gave up
then you woke up so like well you know
what i didn't want to go interfere with
this but
you're doing okay but if you take his
hand just wait and just push a little
bit down
he'll be tapping out right away so i
just like try it
i say [ __ ] i wish i knew that i would
spend 30 minutes trying to
get my arm over and here's a simple
technique to do it so
so yeah that's that was pretty funny
when he was that's actually scared me
but because i didn't know it
we were wrestling you were overwatching
us and then that's i'm like i'm doing
pretty good you know
but he's not tapping out so i'm just
wrapping him up
and then i see you and other team guard
other
other guys on the platform just prying
me out of sky that's like
yeah stop stop slow i say stop for
[ __ ] wow that
he's stepping out and saying no he's not
he's stopping out no he's not
and then he say wait uh do you hear did
you hear this
i say yeah but what does that mean
okay so well he couldn't breathe and
he's going to tap there he has no way to
tap out and scott said dude
i couldn't breathe i couldn't tap out so
i could say was i couldn't have a breath
to even say stop and
all i could do is and then uh
and then then you start off so yeah it's
like that's pretty cool actually
i was like wow that's [ __ ] jiu-jitsu
that works man
yeah that particular individual was kind
of claustrophobic and i remember i would
train with him and
when when someone's super claustrophobic
like that sometimes i like to
sort of uh give them some exposure
therapy and try and make them more used
to it but i remember him just
he's going he's just like get off he get
off me and he was so mad to get off me
i'm not down with this and he's walking
up so bad
he was freaking away there was nothing
unusual to see you know where there's
having guys pass out who
good times good times awesome uh
right on echo charles yes speaking of
getting after it speaking of jiu-jitsu
speaking of
you know maintaining the good physical
condition
which i'm really when you're telling me
that you didn't like
work out or anything bro you're a
freaking mutant
because you were strong-ish you're like
oh strong like you're as strong as
[ __ ] to wrestle with man
that's just how uh when i was speaking
to being strong
yeah now that now that i'm speaking that
so when we were lifting we were all
trying to get
jacked so so whatever
if i guess there's nothing i i don't
know if you necessarily brought this
from the eastern bloc
but but drago taught us this thing or
would do this thing where we would lift
when you're getting when you're getting
your lift on
he had this uh primal this primal noise
so so whenever like the platoon was in a
gym somewhere
overseas you'd just hear guys going
yachts
actually you know in iraq yes every
platoon came in
who came through because i was staying
there but platoons rolled through
through bark that
everybody was living with us
and um every every single platoon
i said okay drago we are screaming the
ads for the [ __ ] months here
what the [ __ ] means arts it's like
i don't know it's like it means
everything you know is it good
it's good you know does it suck
so he likes to miss everything yeah i
was talking to my my uh kids
and i was like oh yeah my friends coming
on the podcast today and they're like oh
whatever they don't care
but then i was like this is the guy that
originally said because
when my kids would work out i'd be like
hey look when you're gonna go for that
big clean
you got to get fired up what you got to
do is give yourself a little watch
so speaking of yeah there you go
well that there's in power lifting
there's
that or some version of that and there's
always that
at the end maybe there's like a
physiological technique for that
tightens up when you if you're going to
do it it tightens up kind of your
your uh your posterior chain right like
you got to make your whole your whole
like
rib cage kind of yeah like if you do it
hard
everything's going to get tight
straighten up that spinal area
yeah it's kind of like you know okay so
that there's a method that's
that has a name for it when you yeah
basically
also when you are beating somebody up
and you add this to it this will discuss
them even more
yeah yeah fully but that there is a tech
that technique has a name like to
tighten up everything it's almost like
there's a breath hold
scenario you can call it brace for it or
something no it's like an ep
theory it's yeah it's an odd word i
forget what it is
but when you say that's that's like a
it's like you're not totally holding
your breath you're giving a little air
it's kind of like you know when you get
you know those uh what do you call the
blood pressure things you know you pump
it pumping pot and then you let out a
little bit it's kind of like that
kind of thing anyway i think it's a
furrow technique it doesn't block
completely or breathing it's just uh
yeah it kind of
gives you that extra pressure that you
need but you still have that
like pressure valve yes that's it's true
yeah
so maybe maybe just that's just how you
kind of grew up you know in your mind
you just it came
very natural it's probably what happened
it worked
worked for me for i think for all of us
because all the guys and the
weather team five seven or whatever team
showed up up there
they all end up with ads makes you a
little bit stronger
actually i got the call into a long time
ago i say drago what the [ __ ] that asked
me is that people are always asking me
and i have i don't know what to tell
them i mean
everything dude oh hell yeah one hour
means nothing but it means everything
yeah
yeah it seems like a little deeper when
i was in college i got knee surgery
because i blew on my acl and before i
got surgery i was like okay what's the
recovery time and all this and they're
like you know
it depends and they ask me are you
polish are you do you have any polish
blood
and i said no why i said because polish
people tend to heal
faster so they for real this is what the
literally what the doctor told me
polish and samoan so how come they
didn't ask if you were samoan
they did oh okay they asked you both
yeah but drago doesn't have
someone yeah less relevant we'll just
say i'm just saying his durability may
be attributed to his
genetic you know scenario blood
i'll look at the balance time and maybe
hopefully that will help me get
got through but also i think uh attitude
i was never like i remember we said
before the hell or during the hell week
so why you are here what did you why
would you come to birds and stuff well i
want to try to be a best seller the best
guy i tried to be a ceo i tried this i
tried that
so they came to me i said i'm not
[ __ ] trying anything i'm here to be a
ceo i just
i will be a seal unless i get injured or
kick me out
so uh i'm not trying i'm just on my way
to be a seal
just like i kind of liked it but i got
beat up for that
you're definitely going to get to beat
down for that one makes sense
what do we got man um oops
either way we yes we are on the path
um so on this path not all of us
are quite as durable or maybe we are i
don't know but we got supplementation
jackal fuel so we got stuff for your
joints joint warfare
we have a review we have an automatic
review drago has been drinking
the dak savage drink and
what what what do you think i'm addicted
to it
for many reasons one is that the taste
of it because uh
i i was telling you earlier about those
candies in poland there's
a specific taste of candies that are so
rare that you can actually trade this
candy for
between the kids and there was like a
caramel
white candy within the so
this is it this is this is that candy
which i was always addicted like dr
pepper
when i had the first dr pepper i said
holy [ __ ] this is america you know
it's like we were struggling to have one
candy like this in here you can just go
to the machine and get yourself one
there you go so that i love the taste so
so it tastes like america what america
there you go it's odd because on the way
down here i was thinking about it you
know like a regular
uh we'll call it for lack of a better
term a traditional
energy drink oh an old poisonous energy
so exactly right so poisonous right and
here's the weird thing everyone knows
that
it's so weird how everyone knows that
like if they say okay so let's say you
just
did some jiu-jitsu you just worked out
or something you're like man i'm thirsty
or whatever you know let me go whatever
now i need drinks yeah you were like
you're not going to the soda machine
you're not getting some soda pop
you're not getting it energy like an
energy drink traditional one
that sounds like the last thing you want
to drink you need maybe
yeah but meanwhile meanwhile you can get
america
not only are you kinda in the mood for
it sometimes
um like right after like a hard workout
it's actually good for you yeah
but isn't it weird how everyone just
knows that that an
energy drink it's like known like it's a
known thing it's mainstream already yeah
it's crazy check well if you want to get
those if you want to get some
joint warfare for your joints if you
want to get krill oil for your joints if
you want to get some
what vitamin d3 yeah
which is all kinds of other also very
good for you for many reasons
malk which is protein disguised as
dessert
it's true anyways you can get all this
stuff at jockofuel.com
or you can get you can get the drinks at
wawa out on the east coast
or you can get the stuff at the vitamin
shop yep all available there
and consider getting the subscription so
originusa.com you want a subscription to
this stuff you can save some money
free shipping by the way well that's
kind of a big deal it's not even a by
the way that's
almost the primary reason okay maybe the
primary reason is
we don't wanna not have what we want
when we need it yes
but another good reason is it's
expensive to ship stuff
yeah but if you subscribe shipping is
free and that's cool
boom and you get it every month when you
need you don't run out
it's a big thing it doesn't seem like a
big thing but try to run out
are you going to know it's going to be a
big thing anyway originusa.com that's
where you can sign up
right that's pretty much the main spot
what is the subscription
origin or usability.com that's the spot
right there
also at originusa.com is jiu jitsu stuff
so we talked about jiu jitsu briefly
we could have talked more oh yeah but
you know very effective
but yeah you want some ghees uh
american-made ghees rash guards
other jiu-jitsu stuff other athletic
stuff too yeah origin usa
yeah made in america by the way so drago
i haven't really
dove into this with you but we are we
now have a company where we are making
products in america we're making
jiu-jitsu guys we're making rash guards
we're making boots we're making jeans
we're making everything in america
i know that because i was i was
following you right now
well the freaking crazy thing is like
like for instance jeans everyone gets a
pair of whatever name brand genes
and they think that they're getting an
iconic american gene
but they're not they're actually getting
genes that are made in
communist countries that's where they're
made
so we don't like that we like our
genes to come from america by hard made
by hardworking people
so origin usa dot com
arts
yes yes also on that same sort of tip
let me direct your attention to taco
store
dot com this is where you can get uh you
know more apparel
more representative directly of the path
so discipline equals freedom good all
these things that's where you can get it
we have a subscription situation going
on as well it's a good one
a little bit different designs but still
applicable
it's just fyi so you can get this thing
it's called the shirt locker if you want
to get one of these cool t-shirts
here's the thing because somebody
there's a reason i'm bringing this up if
someone went online and was like
that you posted something and they're
like hey none of these t-shirts are on
the store
on jacquardstore.com and yes and no but
right well explain yes so people do
understand yes they are on jocko store
but they're
only through the subscription scenario
the shirt
locker so that's the only place you can
get them it
again like if you do i mean if you even
care about like the difference
or whatever it's just they're the
designs a little bit
we'll just say they're a little bit more
creative from time to time
nonetheless um you know they're a little
bit different they're cool
they're fun uh you will get a new one
every month
damn there it is there you go uh you can
subscribe to this podcast you can
subscribe to some other podcast we got
the
the unraveling podcast with daryl cooper
we got the grounded podcast we got the
warrior kid podcast there's new episodes
out by the way
yes sir i was really
slow in getting those out but they're
out you can get your warrior kids listen
to those you can also you can also join
the underground jocko underground.com
where we go in a little bit more detail
a little bit of behind the scenes
research yep also some good that
a lot because some people ask like hey
what uh do you guys do q a
yeah still you know i'm wondering about
this and this
good questions but yes the answer is yes
we do do the q a but it's on the
underground
exclusively to the underground maybe
maybe not but currently we don't know
yet
well here's the deal we had people that
signed up to be on the underground that
subscribed to the underground that asked
questions
so we answered their questions on one of
the first uh
underground q and a's so anyways go to
jockowunderground.com
if you want to subscribe to that if you
can't afford it cost eight dollars and
18 cents a month by the way
if you can't afford that look we still
want you to get the information
you can email assistants at
jacounderground.com
we'll take care of you we got a youtube
channel where
uh echo puts videos up that he creates
that he put more too by the way oh
that's some new uh conceptual
ideas okay so if you're waiting for
echo's conceptual ideas they should be
produced within the next 24 months
because his work ethic is well
it's solid dude it's not it's not
he doesn't create videos varying levels
of
happiness maybe you should maybe you
should go home get in front of your
editing suite and just go accident maybe
we'll get some more freaking videos
that's what that's what he's doing
yeah if you guys are legit you know that
odds actually is part of my
uh uh the drago's accelerated english
that's the main motivator people hear
that one time and they're telling you
where their first born child is
they speak very good english after that
uh
psychological warfare you can get that
on any mp3 platform we got flipside
canvas
flipsidecampus.com my brother dakota
meyer
marine corps he's got a company where
he's making things to hang on your wall
we got a bunch of books okay the first
book that i want to talk to you about is
the book that i started
off this podcast today i took one little
section
uh the the book is called and you're
gonna have to help me with all this
uh drago so the book is called camp
posey
the writer his name is how do i say it
navajo novel so novel was a guy in the
grom
in the polish grom special operations
guy
i don't know too much about him because
i can't read polish
but the book is available and i ordered
it but i haven't gotten it yet
it's available on amazon so if you want
to get this book look up camp posey
and it it i i did look through it
there's pictures of
um i mean because he was deployed with
us he was
when you were there and i was there so
uh yeah our pictures
yep there's pictures of where we were
there's pictures of camp jenny posey
which is
freaking brings back all kinds of
memories for us because nostalgia
were doing so much good work out of
there a bunch of pictures in it
and and you can get an english version
so check that out
camp posey have you read it oh i have
read it yes i've read it both and i
read in polish and english and it's very
accurate i say i think it's
it it gives you the the
the the perspective from the other other
guys
who are not part of the sales but they
are really good they they
they and how they perceive seal teams
right
how they see us how what do we do in
iraq and how they work
so it's pretty good insight and the
perspective on sales from the
different vantage point and then what
about this other book that you brought
today which i haven't
seen um so what's this called this is uh
the title of translation is my 13 years
in the uh grom okay so this is
not my thirteen years this is this guy's
that's a 13 right there yes thirteen
that's exactly that's thirteen in polish
so it's
us you are on the english channel dragon
switch mode so this guy was with us too
actually the
hame and the naval naval they were
together in
i think at the same time there so
this is uh he wrote this book much
earlier and
same thing ages his view on the iraq war
on the our working together with seals
and that
how this thing uh uh you know well
i think it's is very interesting
especially if you want to look
and uh about us about sales and how
others perceive us
other forces do you know if this is this
book available on amazon is also
available on amazon it is also
i will send you the links uh it is also
available in english
on amazon so and the and the english
title is also
13 years my 13 years my 13 years
yeah i do i'm just flipping through this
one this one's got a bunch of pictures
very that look very familiar as well
yeah i mean
that was the pictures taken when we were
there yeah that's
freaking awesome all right so we got
these books check these books out
um we and drago and i already talked
about hopefully
getting one of those guys or both those
guys on the podcast at some point if
they can come over here from poland or
maybe you know
what might we make an exception and do a
not live
like not face to face we have never done
that before we've never done a
a virtual podcast maybe we would do it
for po
for poland like skype or something yeah
we have actually one of them i think
we'll be traveling here too
so that's all we need to know just
that'll be awesome if
actually he could trap and tell his
perspective on iraq war
why poland got involved in it and why
poland was
standing by our side uh
in that war and why is poland standing
by our side so be good to hear from yeah
that'd be awesome uh a bunch of other
books too i got a new book coming out
called final spin you can pre-order it
right now
if you want the first to dish i don't
think we've talked about that yet on
final spin
if you want the first have we if you
want that first edition you mentioned it
last time i think but yeah you didn't go
look don't be coming up to me in
whatever when the book comes out two
months after it comes out and you roll
up to me hey
chocolate got your book and i look at it
i'm gonna know
you're gonna know we're all gonna know
we're all gonna know you got the second
dish
uh pre-order that one right now
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocol displaying
freedom field manual way of the warrior
kid one two three and four
check those out mikey and the dragons
which is which is apparently the best
the kids book ever that's what i've
heard
and then about face by david hackworth i
wrote a forward on a new version
pretty honored to do that extreme
ownership the dichotomy leadership
that's the og
of jocko books that i wrote with my
brother leif babin we got a consulting
company salonfront go to
ashlandfront.com
we got ef online if you want online
virtual training
go to efonline.com if you want to come
see us live go to extremeownership.com
we got
three events this year because
we're having three events this year so
if you want to come go to
extremeownership.com it's a leadership
a leadership seminar live in person we
also have an event coming up called
ef battlefield where we walk the
battle of gettysburg we walk the
battlefield there and
talk about the lessons that were learned
this is an unbelievable
event we sold we we were only going to
do one
we sold it out we're doing two now
hopefully
so if we can get things scheduled we're
going to make that happen go to
echelonfront.com
events if you want to come to that and
if you want to help service members
active and retired if you want to help
their families if you want to help gold
star families
check out mark lee's mom she has
her own organization and if you want to
help you want to donate you want to get
involved
go to america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want to hear more from us
which is highly unlikely at this point
but if you want to
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on instagram on facebook echo is
at echo charles
i am out jocko willink now if
you want to talk to drago he's not on
those platforms
his his free speech has been suppressed
but don't worry he's
on the underground he's making things
happen you can check him out at
connectzing.com i'm also on there now
too
because well if drag was there and he's
hanging out
on there and i'm going to be hanging out
too echo you got any final thoughts
no that's it man good to see you again
we met briefly
downtown in my nightclub days with my
good friend jeremy
and he uh he introduced me to you back a
long time ago he was like
almost 20 years like a long time ago say
hi to him this is a great guy
oh yeah i love this guy and uh yeah i
met him i remember dragging i was like
oh
okay all right he seems very nice but
he could probably get nuts so okay good
to see you again
thank you this was nice to see you again
and it was great to be here
draco any other closing thoughts man
um i say maybe make a small
prayer in our mind for those guys who
are no longer with us and
maybe a few seconds of silence
to honor them
yeah and um i don't know when this
podcast is is actually coming out
but um today is is
march 20th today is is mark lee's
birthday and
i mean just an incredible incredible man
incredible seal
husband incredible son
and miss him and the rest of the boys
every day
so
happy birthday to mark and drago
man thanks for your service thanks for
your service to the teams
thanks for your service to the navy
thanks for having my back
countless times thank you for your
service to
america and and beyond that
thanks for your service to the ultimate
cause of
freedom in the world you can't repay
freedom there's people are asking me
thank you this is the other way around
jacob actually
there's me who's supposed to say thank
you to you to you to every america and
for my freedom
what i did in the teams in the navy is
just a token flip for
you cannot repay freedom you could that
freedom is not for sale
it is not there is nothing
you can do to reciprocate that freedom
that
that we that i got from america i'm free
man
and that's awesome feeling it's
something that
i will never be able to reply repay and
i just i believe that just keep serving
in any capacity
i can to our great america
is important so i'm not done yet i've
finished my military career but i'm
still
serving i'm still want to make america
a better and safer place well
i'm into that and uh i know i will
always be proud to call you brother
and to all the other people out there
especially those that are out there
wearing the cloth of the nation thank
you for protecting
the most precious thing that we have and
that is our freedom
and the same goes for our police and law
enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers
border patrol secret service and all the
other first responders out there
thank you for protecting us here at home
and everyone else
just remember that freedom is not free
and we cannot take it for granted
there is evil in the world there is
oppression in the world
and we must be on guard for
authoritarian and tyrannical leaders and
like drago
we must be willing to stand up and fight
for our freedom
and until next time this is drago and
echo
and jocko out